bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
vidéo placée sous le signe de la douleur
la douleur parce que aujourd'hui je vais
m'attaquer à un article absolument
illisible qui s'intitule les dinosaures
n'ont jamais existé absolument illisible
parce que je suis allé jusqu au 1er
paragraphe et honnêtement j'ai pas tenu
le coup alors je vais essayer de faire
une lecture toute entière de cet article
une nature une lecture critique tout
entière de cet article je suis pas sûr
d'arriver au bout ça fait mal aux yeux
ça fait vraiment mal aux yeux et c'est
pas un il s'agit pas d'un article
extrêmement cryptic a en réalité bon bah
il s'agit d'un article qui a été publié
sur le site de et nichane article qui a
des thématiques très classique quand il
s'agit de bullshit ah voilà je vous
laisse une liste défilé devant vous
anciens aliens autre monde contrôle
mental conspirationnisme mêmes mais là
c'est mon préféré quoi et même comment
élever son taux vibratoire avec des
coquilles saint jacques
voilà donc si vous voulez savoir comment
on élève son taux vibratoire avec des
coquilles saint jacques
c'est le site qu'il vous faut après si
vous aimez le bullshit
j'ai comme l'impression qu'on est tombé
sur un très bon client
il se trouve que ce très bon client a
lui même de très bons clients puisqu'il
ya quand même 166 partage de cet article
les dinosaures n'ont jamais existé sur
facebook je crois pas avoir jamais
atteint ce niveau là sur aucune de mes
publications facebook et il ya 3591 vue
sur cet article ce qui veut dire que cet
article fait à peu près 1600 vu de plus
que nos vidéos moyenne quoi voilà dans
nos vidéos dépasse les 2000 vu que quand
on parle d'extra terrestres et de
complotisme et de théories du complot
bref il y a une relation inversement
proportionnelle entre le temps que je
passe à écrire mes vidéos et et le
nombre de vues sur mes vidéos
donc en fait cet article ça va être
l'article de la pénitence j'ai besoin
d'une pénitence parce que j'ai fini par
me dire au bout d'un moment que quand
même je vais peut-être arrêter de
m'emmerder faire des vidéos de merde
parce que c'est mes vidéos de merde qui
sont plus vus donc maintenant pour me
laver de ses pensées impures
il faut que j'explique mes péchés que je
fasse mon chemin de croix et bordel que
cet article va être douloureux ouais je
balance board elle tout de suite parce
que je vous annonce que vu la qualité du
premier paragraphe il est cette vidéo
sera placée sous le signe d'une
vulgarité probablement excessive donc
mais bon trêve de mondanités comment
sont les dinosaures n'ont jamais existé
posté le 24 août 2016 d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire qu il y adeux des
d'autres vidéos qui ont été faites sur
ce thème les dinos george ney dinosaures
n'ont jamais existé des vidéos qui
tournent autour de 7000 8000 vue à
l'heure où j'enregistre et qui ont été
des bunkers donc juste pour vous dire
que les dinosaures n'ont jamais existé
c'est pas nous qui faisons de la pub en
des bonnes quand ça c'est quelque chose
qui a déjà du succès est bon un succès
mitigé à 7000 vu ici 3600 vu c'est pas
non plus le bout du monde mais c'est un
succès qui est quand même déjà plus
grand que celui de notre chaîne donc je
je m'octroie en tant que david de cette
confrontation david contre goliath je
m'octroie le doigt le droit de faire un
petit débat une cage les dinosaures
n'ont jamais existé c'est parti
traduction par helios oui parce que
c'est une traduction reconduite d'acide
d'un autre site dont encore plus il ya
3600 rue mais c'est même pas le premier
site a posté cette merde donc imaginer
le nombre de gens qui ont lu ça et qui
peut être longue mais même un pour cent
de ça c'est déjà trop en substance la
fabrication des dinosaures étaient
indispensables pour faire adhérer le
monde scientifique et secondairement la
population théorie du complot à la
théorie darwinienne de l'évolution
at on besoin des dinosaures pour faire
avaler la théorie de l'évolution
non
absolument pas mais genre absolument pas
darwin n'a pas évoqué une seule fois les
dinosaures dans toute son oeuvre
ou peut-être dans les rééditions mais en
tout cas certainement pas dans
l'original donc non déjà ça c'est faux
que de toute façon les dinosaures
jusqu'à ce qu'on accepte le fait qu'il
que les oiseaux descendent des
dinosaures c'est à dire jusque dans les
années 90 soyons honnêtes les dinosaures
étaient considérés de toute façon comme
un cul de sac évolutif donc évolutive
mans parlant il n'apportait pas grand
chose à la théorie donc déjà
l'introduction zéro nada que dalle
tu sors ses soeurs entre guillemets
parce que danseur ricciardo wen a été
fait chevalier par la reine donc ses
soeurs sans guillemets ses soeurs
ricciardo owen de la société royale et
surintendant du département d'histoire
naturelle du british muséum qui a défini
en 1842 la classe dinosauria en d'autres
mots l'existence des dinosaures s'appuie
au départ sur l' hypothèse théorique
d'un directeur de musée nommé chevalier
comme par hasard au milieu du 19e siècle
âge d'or de l'évolutionnisme avant même
qu'on ait découvert un seul fossiles de
dinosaures pas rouge commence [ __ ] le
mot l'existence s'appuie au départ sur
l' hypothèse théorique alors l'hypothèse
théorique
ça c'est ça c'est beau ça l' hypothèse
théorique il ya des choses il ya des
choses qui sont jolis à dire comme ça là
directeur de musée d'auch mais chevalier
qui comme par hasard au milieu du 19e
siècle
âge d'or de l'évolutionnisme ah bon
l'âge d'or de l'évolutionnisme non je
sais pas l'origine des espèces il a été
publiée au milieu du siècle
donc il ya au moins la moitié de ce
siècle de cet âge d'or qui n'est pas
dédié à l'évolutionnisme alors je vois
pas d'où tu sors ça d'autant que
ricciardo wayne était farouchement
opposé à darwin donc pour le coup tu es
complètement à côté de la plaque
avant même qu'on ait découvert un seul
fossiles de dinosaures bah non c'est
faux puisqu'ils ricciardone a défini la
classe dinosauria pour y placer les
fossiles de mégalo szohr d'iguane aux
dons et le dernier je me rappelle jamais
lequel c
on va chercher sur internet puisque de
toute façon c'est bien l'idée de cette
vidéo c'est de montrer dinosaures
ricciardo owen on va chercher je me
rappelle plus du nom du troisième mais
bref voilà wikipedia mon ami vas tu me
dire il a et aux eaux russes voilà un an
qui l'odeur il a et aux eaux russes donc
mégalo zaurus iguanodon et il a et aux
eaux russes donc il est dit que les
fossiles étaient déjà découvert vous
pouvez le vérifier par vous même sur
internet
c'est bien pour ça que je fais cette
vidéo c'est pour vous montrer qu'il n'ya
rien d'inaccessible dans pour vérifier
le vérifier les affirmations de ces gens
là les organes de presse tant maçonnique
que grand public démarrèrent un battage
publicitaire sur ses supposées animaux
depuis longtemps disparu je m'arrête pas
sur le complot franc maçon je suis au
dessus de ça et surprise douze ans plus
tard en 1854 ferdinand vente divers
hayden lors de son exploration de la
vallée du missouri découvrit une preuve
de la théorie de wayne quelques dents
non identifié qui l'envoyaient au pathé
le paléontologue réputé joseph lady qui
déclara plusieurs années plus tard
qu'elle provenait d'un ancien dinosaures
et a le trac aux dons ce qui veut dire
toute ironie à part dans grossière le
traque aux dons ça me dit absolument
rien je crois que vous venez d'inventer
l'histoire très cher ah non ça existe de
traque aux dons au temps pour moi du
bios genuis aube
adro zoric donc à un genre douteux dadre
aux orres donc c'est un bref
ouais mais non comme je le disais on
avait déjà découvert des restes de
dinosaures 1
en 1854 est ce qu on avait déjà
découvert l'archaeopteryx attend le
vérifie l'archaeopteryx and en 1860
l'archaeopteryx autant pour moi donc on
en est pas encore à découvrir des
dinosaures à plumes à l'époque mais bon
on avait déjà des dinosaures plus qu'il
n'en fallait un dire robert pilotte
avaient découvert mégalo zaurus 1 depuis
très longtemps
roberte pelote mai
l'eau aux russes regardez roberte pelote
donc c'était aux 10es au xviie siècle
donc c'était au moins un siècle avant je
le rappelle plus exactement la date mais
ouais effectivement sauter n'ont même
pas là on est au 19e siècle en fait avec
ricciardo wen au 19e siècle donc c'était
deux siècles avant qu'on avait découvert
ce fémur de mégalo zaurus donc tu es
complètement à côté de la plaque
on continue tout d'abord pas besoin de
préciser qu'il est impossible de
reconstituer l'intégralité d'un animal
hypothétique disparu tout en se basant
sur quelques dents bassi pourvu qu'on
ait des des équivalents actuels
je veux dire enfin un animal s'ils
avaient des dents c'est qu'il avait des
mâchoires s'il avait une mâchoire c'est
qu'il avait une tête je veux dire ça ça
va quoi c'est pas la fin du monde mais
il est encore plus douteux que
d'innombrables formes intermédiaires
ancien reptiles oiseaux et reptiles
mammifères nécessaires à la théorie en
plein essor de l'évolution fasse d'abord
l'objet d'une hypothèse est soit ensuite
découverte forte à propos par des
équipes d'archéologues évolutionniste
cherchant à dessein de tels faux cils
pétain des paléontologues déjà des
[ __ ] de paléontologues pas des
archéologues mais teddy wayne non ben
encore une fois c'est hypothèse de base
fausse puisque non on n'a pas découvert
les fossiles
après avoir inventé le mot d'innocents
on avait on a inventé le mot dinosaures
pour qualifier ces fossiles fossiles
qu'on découvrait déjà depuis longtemps
comme le démontre l'histoire de robert
pilotte qui deux siècles avant
découvrait déjà des fossiles de
dinosaures et si on va dans ce terrain
là d'ailleurs j'aimerais vous fera pas
j'aimerais faire remarquer que nous
avons fait une vidéo qui s'appelle
dinosaures et dragon et dans cette vidéo
que vous voyez s'afficher un instant on
vous parle on vous parle on vous parle
des fossiles voilà mes relais ça si
c'est pas mignon
on vous parle des fossiles qui ont été
trouvés à travers les âges à travers le
monde donc là c'est par exemple le
dessin d'une empreinte de pas de
dinosaures qui a été fait par des
indiens d'amérique avant la colonisation
donc les indiens d'amérique trouvait
déjà des empreintes de pas de dinosaures
alors on sait que c'est une empreinte de
pas de dinosaures et non pas un cactus
parce qu'il ya un cactus des signes est
juste à côté parce que précisément un
peu à côté de ces empreintes de ses
dessins d'empreintes
il y à de véritables emprunte donc les
indiens d'amérique avaient trouvé des
empreintes de dinosaures bien avant
qu'on invente le mot dinosaures et c'est
le cas aussi des aborigènes d'australie
voilà donc le émeut le eme man l'homme
et me les aborigènes d'australie ont
probablement inventé la légende de
l'homme et me autour des empreintes de
pas de dinosaures qui est vous pouvez
voir d'ailleurs que le pied d'un et me
ressemble énormément à celui de d'un
pied de dinosaures enfin à celui d'un
dinosaure du coup et en afrique du sud
aussi on a découvert des on a découvert
que les bushmen connaissait l'existence
d'empreintes de pas alors d'empreintes
de pas de dinosaures fossilisé donc tout
ça s'est résumé dans un article alors
falloir que je le retrouve c'est un
article qui avaient été publiées dans
hick noces donc oui adrienne mayor et
william sargent qui ont publié sur le
sujet voilà c'est en ligne donc si vous
voulez accéder à l'article
servez-vous est justement dans cet
article il vous parlerons de tout les
toutes les empreintes de pas fossiles
qui ont été identifiées identifié avant
l'ère scientifique
voilà donc bien avant qu'on invente le
mot dinosaures donc tous à la bullshit
voilà pourquoi les indiens n'en n'ont
jamais découvert pendant toutes les
années où ils ont remporté lé continent
d'amérique bah tiens et jeu je n'ai pas
lu 1
je n'ai pas lu cet article mais tu vois
là tout de suite tout de suite après ils
te sortent les analysons n'ont jamais
trouvé
faux faux faux faux voilà allez voir
l'article
allez voir la vidéo il n'y a aucune
croyance associés aux dinosaures dans
les relie dans la religion ou la
tradition des amérindiens
faux faux faux faux voilà encore une
fois retournés ici toc c'est faux et il
y avait même des croyances associés aux
fossiles de big boom lic donc les
fossiles qui sont dans le lac big john
qui tient son nom du fait qu'on trouve
des fossiles dedans c'est pas des
fossiles de
dinosaures c'est des faux cils
pléistocène du mammouth et du bison
géant mais il y avait un folklore
associés aux fossiles adrienne mayor a
écrit tout un bouquet là dessus voilà à
thann et je vous l'envoie adrienne mayor
folklore américain
normalement on doit pouvoir le trouver
voilà adrienne mayor fassoles fassoles
legends of the first americans
il ya tout un bouquin qui est des qui
est fait sur sa paru en 2007
cet article xi a été retweeté un fartage
et en 2016 vous n'avez aucune excuse
pour votre ignorance suivant pourquoi
d'ailleurs n'y at il aucune découverte
antérieure au 19e siècle il y en a dans
une quelconque partie du monde
selon la world book encyclopedia dorbani
dont elle revient tonicité encarta dit
mois avant les années 1800 personne ne
connaissait l'existence des dinosaures
c'est normal le mot n'avait pas été
inventée connard on a découvert deux
grands gisements de fossiles de
dinosaures à la fin des années 1800 et
au début des années 1900 oui là où on a
vraiment commencé à aller chercher
pourquoi l'homme at-il fait soudas
toutes ces découvertes
parce qu'on a commencé à aller chercher
le mot dinosaures ayant été inventé au
moins on avait une cible parce qu'avant
il n'y avait pas de cible on les
trouvait un peu au bonheur la chance
aucune tribu culture au pays du monde
n'a découvert le moindre os de
dinosaures avant le milieu des années
1800 c'est faux et on en a trouvé
ensuite tout autour du monde en amérique
du nord en amérique du sud europe asie
afrique argentine mongolie tanzanie et
de nombreux autres endroits possédait
apparemment de grands gisements de
fossiles de dinosaures jamais découvert
auparavant
c'est faux donc je vous renvoie à l'air
l'article d'adrienne mayor je vous
renvoie aussi un autre livre d'adrienne
mayor qui s'intitule de first fassoles
hunters
je n'ai pas bien écrit hunters mais
c'est pas grave il le trouve quand même
voilà the first fassoles hunters qui
vous racontent l'histoire des
découvertes de fossiles pendant
l'antiquité grecque romaine et
égyptienne donc grecque romaine c'est en
europe égyptienne c'est en afrique et
ils vous parlent aussi occasionnels elle
vous parle aussi au gaz
tellement du fameux mythe du griffon qui
est en asie donc tous les continents
tout va bien et on à l'autre bouquin qui
est consacrée à l'amérique donc on a
tous les continents
tout va bien on continue l'article
première ligne en gras attention tous
ces endroits étaient habitées et bien
explorée depuis des milliers d'années
avant cette date pourquoi personne
n'at-il jamais trouvé avant parce qu'on
a alors déjà c'est faut d'une part je le
répète et d'autre part parce qu'on ne
savait pas parce qu'on n'était pas
intéressé de les trouver tout simplement
je veux dire on trouvait des gros être
bien la belle affaire mais on s'en
foutait un peu d'autant qu'on avait
aucune idée de ce que c'était donc il ya
que quand le mot dinosaure a été inventé
par le génie ricciardo owen que qu'au
final on a pu dire ah bah en fait il ya
des gros reptile qui ont existé avant
mais bon sinon les fossiles on les
trouvait c'est juste qu'on savait pas
comment les interpréter
selon le livre projet dinosaures le
journaliste paléontologues wayne garde y
déclare que pendant la période qui a
suivi entre 1870 et 1880 environ se
pratiquer en amérique du nord certaines
des combinés plus tordus de l'histoire
de la science
bon bah là c'est la référence à la
guerre des os ou effectivement il ya
deux psychopathes qui se sont mis
copé marche qui se sont mis à chercher
des hauts comme des cinglés quitte à
faire les coups bas les plus les plus
malsains mais bon je veux dire les coups
bas que ce soit en sciences ou dans
n'importe quel autre discipline sur
discipline dans n'importe quel autre
contexte humain je lis à partir du
moment où il ya des humains il ya des
coups bas quoi je vois pas le problème
pendant ce qu'on a appelé le grand rush
vers les dinosaures ou la guerre des
ossements une rivalité est une passion
de toute une vie pour la chasse aux
dinosaures commença entre edward drink
coop de l'académie des sciences
naturelles et hotmail marches du musée
peabody ils étaient amis au début mais
il devint ensuite des ennemis acharnés
au cours d'une querelle légendaire où se
mêlèrent trahison calomnie corruption
vol espionnage et destruction
d'ossements
je suis d'accord pour une fois il ya une
phrase qui dit pas des conneries vous
pouvez aller voir la vidéo de sim plex
paléo sur ce sujet d'ailleurs qui est
très très bien et qui confirmera cette
version des faits on disait que marche
avait découvert plus de 500 anciennes
espèces différentes dont 80 dinosaures
alors que coop n'aurait découvert que 56
je connais pas les chiffres somme
ça m'a l'air correct sur les 136 espèce
de dinosaure corps est soi-disant
découvert les deux hommes pourtant seuls
32 sont actuellement considérés comme
valides c'est vrai parce qu'ils ont fait
du travail de cochon ont vu qu'ils
allaient très vite
le reste s'est révélée de 2 total
falsification et fabrication
c'est faux ils ont simplement été mises
en synonymie misant synonymie ça veut
pas dire falsification ça veut juste
dire que dans la précipitation ils ont
décrété qu'ils avaient trouvé une
nouvelle espèce alors qu'en fait
c'étaient des espèces qu'ils avaient
déjà découvert aucun des deux n'a jamais
déclaré non plus avoir trouvé de
squelettes complets tout leur travail
supposé donc des reconstitutions c'est
faux je connais pas encore une fois je
ne connais pas le détail historique mais
je sais que coupe si je me rappelle bien
a découvert un squelette entier
délassement or je sais que c'est pas un
dinosaure mais ça reste un reptile marin
fera ça reste un reptile mésozoïque et
il a découvert un squelette tout entier
dont il ne manquait que la tête ce qui
lui a d'ailleurs n'ont même pas élu il
avait la tête c'est juste qu'il n'a pas
placer du bon côté de l'animal il l'a
placé sur le sur l'accueil lieu de la
placer sur le coup mais sinon il avait
un squelette entier des l'asmo szohr il
me semble que brontosaure us ou à pato
au russe était entier qu'en marche l'a
découvert donc non ça ça par contre
c'est faux ça que je suis à peu près sûr
que c'est faux professeur à la wikipédia
brontosaure us en 1879 professeur
hotmail charles marsh professeur de
paléontologie aliens à l'université yale
annonce la découverte d'un d'un énorme
est quasiment complet sauropodes
squelette de sauropodes de la formation
morrison qui livrent d'ailleurs de
magnifiques squelette complet
je ne résiste pas à l'envié de vous les
montrer
mais voilà donc le bronze au russe a
bien été trouvées complet par au tinel
charles marsh voilà complète skelton
morrison formation voilà ce qu'on trouve
à la formation morrison
il ya toute une exposition d'ailleurs il
me semble que c'est la formation
morrison que justement ils ont arrêté de
déterrer les trucs et ils préfèrent les
montrer il ya un genre de hangars qui
est construit par dessus j'espère que je
dis pas de connerie et que c'est bien la
formation morrison qu'ils ont fait ça je
me rappelle où c'est aux dinosaures
monument
allez bref mais de toute façon il ya
suffisamment d'endroits en amérique du
nord on trouve des squelettes de
dinosaures tout entier pour que j'ai pas
trop à douter de ce que je veux ce que
je suis en train de dire quoi voilà
regardez là celui là il est complète
chez complet et voilà y'a pas à
tortiller du cul quoi on continue ou en
étage où en étais-je de ses salades en
fait à ce jour aucun squelette complet
n'a été découverte de tous les et tous
les dinosaures sont donc des
reconstitutions au le raccourci quoi le
dire même en admettant que le kop elle
marche et jamais trouvé de squelette
complet je veux dire d'aller vers le
raccourci qui consiste à dire en fait on
en a jamais trouvé de notre vie wouah
depuis 200 ans tu crois qu'on n'a jamais
trouvé de squelettes complets gros et
ben non des squelettes complets on en a
on en a beaucoup on en a beaucoup on
cherchait pas à enfin est-ce que faut
vraiment que je vous démontre ce à quoi
des squelettes complets on attend plus
de toute façon jean pas pourquoi je me
pose la question regarder il est là il
est là il est encore sûr il ya encore
encasté dans la roche là il y a encore
dire des squelettes complets on en a
plein regardez et tenait un des plus
récents qui a été trouvé non non on n'a
jamais trouvé de dinosaures complet
voilà ce pilote c'est peanuts et pas un
dinosaure complet ça voyons il a juste
la peau et les muscles avec quoi c'est
tout près le squelette il est en dessous
il ya il ya des craquelures là on a bien
vu que le squelette était en dessous non
on ne trouve pas de dinosaures complet
bien sûr que non voyons quelles idées
quelle idée non donc bravo merci mais au
suivant il semble que les découvertes et
les fouilles ne sont pas faites par des
gens désintéressés comme des
agriculteurs des éleveurs des
randonneurs des promeneurs des ouvriers
maniant des pelleteuses pour creuser les
fondations des bâtiments
ah bon il n'y a pas de découvertes de
fossiles fait par hasard alors à temps
et évasif je suis sûr qu'il n'ya pas
longtemps il ya encore un gamin qui a dû
découvrir un truc donc on va taper kid
discovers fassoles voilà kit discovers
au sol et on va dans les news de google
voilà une fille de six ans
trouve un fossile un enfant un enfant
pendant ses vacances trouve un fossile
donc un enfant trouve un fossile et je
veux dire vatea mars 2010 8 28 mars 2010
8 19 juillet 2017
c'est il ya quand même pas aller
chercher loin donc à temps on va voir
quand même si c'est pas exactement la
même histoire mais reprises 3 fois
une fillette de six ans qui trouve des
petits fossiles bon à la trouverez une
ammonite c'est pas non plus la fin c'est
pas non plus un dinosaure donc admettons
à la un enfant en vacances trouve une
mâchoire de mastodontes voit la paf la
grosse mâchoire deux mastodontes de uche
et dans national geographic qui sont pas
les derniers des couillons vingt et un
enfants pendant une randonnée découvre
un fossile de plusieurs millions
d'années est ce qu'il s'agit d'un
dinosaure est ce qu'il s'agit d'un
dinosaure un an c'est un steak au
mastodonte donc c'est encore un
mastodonte
c'est encore un fossile de d'éléphant
bon c'est pas du fossile de dinosaure ça
je suis d'accord on est je vous de la
corde
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on que des
gamins trouve des fossiles regardez là
encore un fossile de 1 million d'années
là c'est un fossile de 90 millions
d'années de poissons dont je veux dire
des enfants qui découvrent des fossiles
de plusieurs millions d'années il y en a
un bon après évidemment dans les news il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de dinosaures
parce que c'est pas non plus tous les
jours quand on tient du dinosaure mais
voilà quoi donc non encore une fois
affirmation fausse complètement fausses
qui creusent des tranchées d'oléoducs et
travaille dans l'exploitation minière
mais plutôt des gens personnellement
très investie comme les paléontologues
et scientifiques les professeurs
d'université le personnel d'organisation
des musées qui faisaient délibérément
une recherche d'ossements de dinosaures
et qui les avait déjà étudié
je rappelle aussi que la paléontologie
elle a une communauté d'amateurs
non parce que bon faudrait aussi le dire
il ya une communauté d'amateurs qui
n'ont pas spécialement de diplômes est
qui et qui cherchent des fausses il ya
des gens qui cherchent des fossiles
juste pour leur plaisir et pas forcément
pour servir les intérêts de l'académie
parce que c'est ce que ce texte
sous-entend là il ya clairement une
théorie du complot là dessous donc voilà
allez voir par exemple la chaîne tenait
à paléo
auld voilà vous allez voir la chaîne de
mon ami si cannes de paléo world qui
n'est pas paléontologues
il ya des vidéos où il va aller en
vadrouille à la recherche de fossiles et
ils trouvent des fossiles de dinosaures
il ya cette vidéo très intéressante tête
est là qu elle s voilà les dinosaures de
la côte atlantique où le vadrouille dans
le veilhan il ya une
il ya une vidéo aussi où il va en
provence donc là il trouve des
empreintes de dinosaures si je me
rappelle bien dans ces deux vidéos là et
il ya une vidéo où il va se balader en
provence où ils trouvent des oeufs de
dinosaures
donc je suis désolé il n'y a pas deux il
n'y a pas de pas de complot il n'y a pas
de complot il ya des gens qui ne sont
pas des académiques qui trouvent des
fossiles oui je me permets une petite
aparté de montage il ya aussi des
créationnistes qui trouvent des fossiles
donc là en l'occurrence un cas de 2015
d'un créationnistes canadien qui a
trouvé des poissons vieux de 60 millions
d'années
donc il n'ya pas que les gens intéressés
par l'évolution qu'ils trouvent des
fossiles il ya aussi des gens qui n'y
croient pas qu'ils n'en croit pas un mot
donc désolé je reprends donc les
trouvailles sont souvent faites par ces
gens au cours de voyages et d'expédition
spéciale de chasse à l'os de dinosaure
dans les régions déjà habité et explorer
ce qui semble hautement invraisemblable
pourquoi pourquoi cette invraisemblable
de monter une expo c'est invraisemblable
de monter une expédition pour aller
chercher des fossiles encore une fois si
cannes de paléo world voilà n'importe
qui peut le faire je veux dire n'importe
qui peut le faire il ya des choses qui
s'appelle des gisements de fossiles des
endroits où il ya eu une préservation un
peu meilleure qu'ailleurs des endroits
aussi où la roche est mieux exposés
qu'ailleurs et donc oui il ya des
endroits où on trouve plus de fossiles
qu'ailleurs donc on monte des
expéditions pour y aller quel est le
problème
ce qui semble hautement invraisemblable
plus crédible et le cas de la découverte
des premiers rouleaux originaux de la
mer morte en 1947 qui furent découverts
sans le vouloir par un enfant qui furent
touche publié en 1955
aucun rapport aucun rapport j'ai déjà
parlé d'enfants qui découvrait des
choses par hasard donc voilà aucun
rapport dans certains cas de découverte
d'ossements de dinosaures par une
personne désintéressé à attention le
complot revient dans certains cas de
découverte d'ossements de dinosaures par
une personne désintéressé un
professionnel entre guillemets dans le
domaine lui suggérerais de regarder ou
de creuser dans une zone particulière oh
bah dis donc qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça c'est l'emploi du conditionnel que en
gros ça veut dire que les personnes
désintéressées
c'est nous les méchants académique qu on
lui suggère d'aller creuser là juste là
oui c'est cela
non moi j'ai des enfants téléguidé jeu
j'ai des enfants téléguidé à implanter
sur puce qui vont exactement chercher
des fossiles pour moi en fait je sais
dgg des petits esclaves télécommandé non
mais sérieusement très intéressant aussi
à noter non mais c'est pas intéressant à
noter on note des faits là tu viens de
faire une étude vient de faire une
supposition labrecque très intéressant
aussi à noter ce sont les zones
spéciales réservées et désigné comme
park à dinosaures ou les chasseurs de
dinosaures amateurs doivent obtenir
d'abord un permis de chasse aux
dinosaures
oui ça s'appelle de la protection de
patrimoine connard ça évite que les
zones soient complètement pillé comme ça
a été le cas par exemple à rennes le
château
à rennes le château on avait trouvé des
oeufs de dinosaures et il a fallu finir
par grillagée la zone parce que les gens
venaient se servir en oeuf de dinosaure
sans rien demander parce que
particulièrement en france parce que il
n'ya aucune protection
y'a aucune loi qui protège le patrimoine
fossiles le patrimoine archéologique oui
à partir du moment où ça a été
manufacturés par l'homme ça devient du
patrimoine archéologique et ses protégés
mais en france si on fout pas du
grillage les fossiles y dégage c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on travaille comme
des cochons je pas si vous avez remarqué
mais les archéologues qui prennent le
temps de mettre des carroyage et tout ça
ils font ça bien les archéologues couche
après couche
les paléontologues ils font ça dans le
rush pourquoi parce que s'ils laissent
les fossiles exposé plus d'une nuit
eh ben le lendemain ils reviennent ya
plus rien voilà donc oui on définit des
parkas dinosaures pour protéger le
patrimoine bande de glands pas bande de
glands qu'ils ont élus qui ont écrit ce
à quoi évidemment quelle que soit la
destination prise par ces archéologues
et paléontologues parce qu'il faut bien
dire les deux cantons c'est pas la
différence
financé par l'establishment le complot
revient il semble que je vais relire la
phrase quelle que soit la destination
prise par ces archéologues et
paléontologues financé par
l'establishment
il semblait trouver des quantités
incroyables de fossiles dans des zones
minuscule ça s'appelle anne
affleurements dans l'un des plus grands
sites de fouilles de dinosaures nommé
ruth mason carrie plus de 2000 fossiles
aurait été découvert oui et alors de
nous faire croire que c'est improbable
de trouver des fossiles dans un endroit
c'est n'importe quoi il ya un truc qui
s'appelle par exemple je sais pas si
c'est le cas de roots mason car il ya
des choses qui s'appelle des
déprédateurs trappe donc des pièges à
predator des prêts je vais y arriver
des pièges à prédateur est un piège à
prédateurs en gros c'est une valve ben
voilà c'est ça il ya une bestiole qui
est morte au milieu
voilà une flaque de boue bon voilà c'est
comme ça qu'ils expliquent par exemple à
la c1 stégosaure milieu avec deux
allosaure autour si je me trompe pas qui
vient du reportage de la bbc walk with
dinosaur main sur la terre des
dinosaures et donc vous avez un piège à
prédateur c'est à dire une pro milieu
des prédateurs qui viennent pour la
bouffe et qui sans qui s'enlise dans la
boue et d'autres prédateurs qui viennent
bouffer ce qui reste et qui s'enlise
dans la boue et ainsi de suite
c'est un phénomène qui existe encore
aujourd'hui et puis voilà je n'irai pas
de ya pas de mystère on peut trouver une
grande quantité de fausses il ya des
phénomènes moderne connu où les fossiles
de les fossiles s'entassent quoi enfin
où les futurs possibles les cadavres
s'entassent des moulages et des
squelettes originaux assemblée à partir
de ces eaux sont actuellement exposées
dans plus de soixante musées du monde
on doit à florentino à merino ou amegee
nos âmes et ami gino
ça dépend d'où vous venez j'imagine
directeur de paléontologie au musée la
plata l'étonnante découverte de 6000
espèces fossiles pendant sa carrière en
argentine
florentino a mais gino amegee noah
merino je ne sais pas comment se
prononce son nom wii est très connu pour
avoir découvert beaucoup de faux cils
c'est c'est ce qui arrive quand on sort
les doigts du cul c'est quelque chose
qui arrive quand quand les gens se
sortent les doigts du cul pour chercher
des choses il les trouve ça arrive ça
arrive c'est pas comme le connard qui a
écrit cet article et qui est resté
devant son ordinateur à rien branler
1les les gens qui se penche pour
regarder voix et les gens qui ne veulent
pas voir disent qu'il ne se passe rien 1
voilà bah là on est clairement face à ça
on est clairement face à un connard qui
s'est pas du tout l'arrêt
connais pas la réalité du terrain le
chasseur de dinosaures heures le douglas
a envoyé trois cent cinquante tonnes
d'ossements de dinosaures résultats de
sa vie de fouilles au musée car negi
d'histoire naturelle provenant tous du
dinosaure nationale mesures monument
dans l'utah durant une expédition en
patagonie le docteur luis chiappe et
docteur le wedding aurait découvert des
milliers 2 de dinosaures sur un site de
seulement quelques ha ouais donc là je
vois où il veut en venir en gros c'est
impossible de trouver autant de choses
ben comme je disais sortir les doigts du
cul va voir la formation morrison va sur
le terrain donc par exemple le mois en
afrique du sud
bah ouais tu mets une semaine avant de
trouver ton premier fossile globalement
tu marches comme un connard dans le
désert pendant des heures et tu passes
une semaine 8h20 tu passes 10 heures par
jour huit à dix heures par jour sous le
soleil à marcher comme un con sans rien
trouver et puis au bout d'une semaine
une fois que tu t'es fait l'oeil
une fois que les autres ont montré ce
qu'ils avaient trouvé une fois que tu
arrives à identifier ce que tu cherches
et bah là tu trouves et 1 et pour le
coup là dans le désert du karoo on en
trouve effectivement des centaines des
centaines et des centaines en quinze
jours je me rappelle une des campagnes
de fouilles qu'on a fait les plus
fructueuses on a ramené presque 200
fossiles 200 fossiles en quinze jours
donc je vais dire voyez toute une vie
moi je vois je vois aucun problème à ce
qu'un monsieur florenty noah maginot ou
bien ces messieurs earl douglas ramène
des tonnes et des tonnes de fossiles
après toute une vie de travail n'ont
aucun aucun souci un absolument aucun
souci en continuant de nombreux experts
ont mentionné que la découverte d'une
telle quantité de fossiles dans une
seule zone part à seulement quelques
individus fortement investi s'oppose aux
lois de la probabilité et rend crédible
de probables contrefaçon ou des efforts
d'implantation localisé à laon s'engage
on s'engage qu'est ce que je disais tout
à l'heure oui le connard qui connaît
rien à la réalité du terrain donc là on
a le connard qui ne connaît rien à la
réalité du terrain mais qui en plus est
un gratte-papier le monsieur gratouille
du papier il fait des calculs non non
non c'est impossible de trouver autant
de fossiles
[ __ ] mais va à la sainte victoire
c'est en france quoi bouge ton cul va la
sainte-victoire non 300 c'est une
traduction d'un site anglais mais je
veux dire les légendes les français qui
ont reporté ce à quoi aller à la
montagne sainte-victoire aller à aix en
provence aller à montpellier allait
aller au tour de mèze
promenez-vous dans les vignes et vous
les verrez les autres dinosaures là
puisqu'on parle d'oeuvre de dinosaures
il ya des oeufs de dinosaures
le sol est pétri de de dinosaure dans le
sud de la france
à certains endroits évidemment c'est pas
partout que le crétacé supérieur
continental à fleurs donc évidemment que
c'est pas partout mais pas les awards
vous le montrera d'ailleurs il a une
vidéo là dessus pas les awards de
dinosaures voilà alexis rastier oeufs de
dinosaures à bâle il a fait sa vidéo
avec paléo world justement voilà alexis
rastier que voici que voilà a fait une
vidéo avec pas les awards où il parle
des oeufs de dinosaures et autant pour
moi c'est pas cette vidéo là où il est
allé voit la sortie à la sainte victoire
autant pour moi alexis rastier il a fait
une vidéo
sorti à la sainte victoire qui cette
fois ci est une vidéo voilà donc ça
c'est ce qui arrive quand on se sort les
doigts du cul qu'on se déplace on trouve
des fossiles des vrais voilà donc ça
commence à devenir un peu relou lavaud
histoire de complot non il n'y a pas de
complot il ya juste des gisements bande
de clowns clan par de grands peintres
on va mélanger les deux les oeufs de
dinosaures ce ventre les os de
dinosaures se vendent
non pas par les musées non non na na na
les u les noms les os de dinosaures se
vendent contre beaucoup d'argent dans
les ventes aux enchères
oui quand ils sont trouvés par des gens
qui ne sont pas des académiques
quand ils sont trouvés par des
compagnies privées dont c'est le métier
de trouver des dinosaures avant les
musées pour pouvoir les vendre plus
rapidement
et oui bande de glands du voile à cette
phrase est l'exemple même de l'acompte
de l'ape du contre arguments voilà c'est
un contre argument ils sont vendus dans
des ventes aux enchères oui par des
particuliers pas par des musées c'était
particulier qui n'ont pas de qui n'ont
pas de lien avec l'académie qui trouve
ses autres dinosaures vendu aux enchères
glandus c'est un marché juteux
oui qui ne profite pas à l'académie qui
ne profite pas aux universités
puisqu'ils sont fait encore une fois par
deux particuliers on exhorte les
spécialistes a publié des articles
oui qui article qui ne rapporte rien qui
coûte plus cher d'ailleurs à publier
parce que le système de publication
pour ceux qui ne le connaissent pas je
voulais l'expliquent les scientifiques
écrivent des articles
les scientifiques contacter les revues
les scientifiques paye les revues pour
pouvoir publier dedans et ensuite les
scientifiques repaye les revues pour
pouvoir accéder aux articles qu'ils ont
écrit
donc les articles publiés ne nous
rapporte ria ils nous coûtent la peau du
cul en réalité donc on exhorte les
spécialistes a publié des articles
oui encore une fois c'est un argument
qui va contre eux ce que tu essayes de
dia les musées font le commerce
d'exposition populaire et attirante
puis même si même s'ils en font le
commerce c'est pas un marché
particulièrement juteux
les producteurs de films et les médias
ont besoin de produire du matériel à
vendre pour rester dans la course il n'y
a pas un rond qui va aux universités
encore une fois il n'ya pas un rond de
jurassic park qui a fini dans les poches
d'une université éventuellement dans les
poches du paléontologue jack horner qui
a été le seul paléontologues consultés
sur le tournage de jurassic park mais
autrement non pas vraiment non
les médias grand public adore faire une
grande publicité autour de supposées
découverte de dinosaures oui mais encore
une fois on ne touche rien on gagne
beaucoup à transformer la plate
découverte d'un homme d'origine moderne
en une trouvaille impressionnante et a
laissé faire là l'imagination d'artistes
pour interpréter et les mettre en valeur
en hausse de rigide moderne alors encore
une fois quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas la
réalité du terrain un homme d'origine
moderne c'est très léger comparé à un os
de dinosaures qui a passé 60 millions
d'années sous terre et qui pèse juste
deux tonnes parce qu'il est il est
complètement cristallisé rempli de
sédiments donc il n'ya pas trop à
confondre ananos d'origine moderne avec
un os de dinosaures rien que le poids le
dire mais ça c'est encore une fois
quelqu'un qui ne connaît pas la réalité
du terrain
il ya des gens avec une folle envie de
prestige de renommée et d'attention
comme le connard qui a écrit cet article
il y à l'effet de mode et de
comportement de la foule comme les
connards qui partagent cet article et il
ya ensuite des gens et des entités qui
poursuivent des un jardin politiques et
religieux comme les connards qui
partagent cet article les bénéfices
financiers économique hautement
gratifiant qui reviennent aux organismes
d'éducation et de recherche au
département universitaire de
paléontologie comme je les dis non c'est
pas vrai y'a rien qui finit dans les
poches des paléontologues aux
découvertes et propriétaires d'os de
dinosaures et aux industries du livre de
la télévision du cinéma et des médias
seront des motifs suffisants pour
ridiculiser tout franche remise en
question et supprimer toute
investigation honnête attend toi toi mon
ami qui a partagé ce magnifique article
qui dénonce les gens qui publie des
choses dans un but lucratif
au fait un don sur paypal au n'aurais tu
pas partager cet article dans un but
lucratif me dis donc
est ce que tu te ferais pas un peu de
notre gueule
mais pas de bol pour toi tu as mis ta
photo sur internet maintenant tu vas te
faire lyncher quelle que soit la
destination prise par sa non pardon je
me suis trompé de paraphes au temps pour
moi non au bout d'un moment je fini par
lâcher des eaux de entre guillemets
t-rex qui se sont vendus pour plus de 12
millions de dollars aux enchères montre
combien lui
créative peut-être le domaine de la
chasse aux dinosaures pour les
particuliers pour pour ces entreprises
qui les trouvent ce ne sont pas les
dinosaures vendu aux enchères ne
proviennent pas de fouilles muséal ils
proviennent de particuliers
je veux dire alors enchères en anglais
ça se dit auction dinosaures voilà on va
essayer de trouver donc le new york post
las vegas auction voilà vous imaginez
bien qu'un truc vendu à las vegas je
m'aime pas sûr qu'ils amusent et à las
vegas quoi donc un fossile vendus à
paris 29 8 langues l'ananas qui à la
provenance
le squelette qui est maintenant exhibé
dans la cité dans la ville de lyon par
dont les possibles acheteurs sont les
musées c'est pas les musées qui les
vendent ces les musées qui les achètent
et le voilà le squelette il a été trouvé
au wyoming en 2013 et appartient à un
businessman voilà allez voir sur le site
des actionnaires donc des vendeurs
d'enchères d'assaut terbi par exemple et
vous verrez que c'est les vendeurs sont
jamais des musées quoi donc non encore
une fois c'est un marché lucratif
je l'admets très lucratif mais pas pour
les musées pas pour les universités
c'est pas eux qui font ça les
universités leur devoir ils ont à deux
voire légale de conservation les musées
les universités on va devoir légal de
conservation dans tous les pays donc ils
ont un devoir légal de ne surtout pas
vendre ce qu'ils ont ça c'est peut-être
fait dans le passé ça oublie pas à
l'époque où la régulation était pas
aussi strictes mais maintenant me du lot
non ils ont un devoir de conservation
ils ont le devoir de garder même les
merdes les plus infâmes juste parce que
c'est du faux cils voilà le premier
dinosaure présenter en public a été le
hades rosoor foule qui à l'académie
edwards rinker coupe de sciences
naturelles de philadelphie le premier
dinosaure présenter en public
qu'est ce que vous racontez comment ça
peut enfin je veux dire même en
imaginant que l'histoire soit vraie ce
qui me malere d'être de la main
l'académie edwards ricard coq donc ça
veut dire que ça s'est passé après
qu'une académie a été nommé en l'honneur
du chasseur de fossiles edwards rigueur
coop nom déjà de base
la phrase ne colle même pas en fait ça
ne colle pas le timing est faux le
timing est complètement faux le premier
dinosaure présenter en public je me
rappelle que richard domaine il
présentait déjà des dinosaures en public
l'iguane aux dons et tout ça bien avant
le bien avant que edward rinker coop
commence même à chercher des fossiles
n'importe quoi c'est une co découverte
de joseph laïdi l'estimé professeur de
coop et le raisonnable et le responsable
du trac au dos dans taurus la
reconstitution originale de la dhr aux
russes qui est toujours explique mélange
des nomenclatures enfin mélange de la
nomenclature scientifique avec l'élément
commun c'est douloureux alliant c'est
douloureux
la reconstitution originale de la dhr
aux russes qui est toujours exposée
aujourd'hui montre le moulage en plâtre
d'un énorme reptiles bipèdes debout se
servant de sa queue comme troisième
jambe ce que peu de gens savent
cependant c'est qu'on n'a jamais
découverte de crâne et qu'on a jamais
présenté deux originaux au public
on n'a jamais découvert le crâne de
drouot russe mort là je prend même pas
la peine de vérifier la cible or n'a
jamais trouvé de crâne rouge non non ils
traînent par terre je veux dire il cale
des portes avec tellement ils en
trouvent aller voir ma vidéo j'ai fait
une vidéo
comment elle s'appelle déjà alors stop
stop science comme elle s'appelle le
tired museum sur le terrain de médium
cette option ans les coulisses secrète
du royal tyrrell museum
voilà et il ya un moment dans cette
vidéo où je montre les collections alors
déjà abrité à bord et aux pétales
tannant comment il s'appelle déjà tiens
on n'a pas vérifié tout à leur bord et a
loupé le tas voilà boréale hop et a donc
là vous pouvez voir le
le squelette tout entier là que j'ai eu
l'honneur de voir moi-même
vous pouvez avoir des squelettes tout
entier qui remplissent la salle mais
surtout on est allé voir les collections
donc ce qu'il ya derrière biarritz aussi
d'un j'ai envie de dire on est allé voir
les backstage et dans les backstage et
ben on voit tous les fossiles les
originaux et pas seulement les trucs qui
sont présentés au public
la voyez là il ya les collections et
dans les collections des feux des crânes
il y en a des qui l'automne quoi bon là
c'est les ceratops hier mais faut
arrêter vos conneries quoi la seule
raison pour laquelle on montre pas
d'originaux au public c'est parce que le
public se barre avec des morceaux je
suis désolé de le dire mais au muséum
d'histoire naturelle
heureusement que c'est pas un original
de diplodocus qui est présenté à paris
au muséum d'histoire naturelle
heureusement que c'est un moulage parce
qu'il ya des gens qui se barre avec les
phalanges et les vertèbres de là que
vous pouvez aller voir au muséum
d'histoire naturelle à paris
si vous avez moins de 25 ans l'entrée y
est gratuite et vous verrez qu'ils
manquent des morceaux 1 c'est parce que
les gens se barre avec et ça devient
grave quand c'est de l'original au
muséum d'histoire naturelle toujours si
vous allez en ahl étage du dessous
l'état joue il ya les squelettes
d'animaux moderne
vous verrez qu'il y à lolo type de la
baleine australe donc lolo type ça veut
dire le spécimen de référence de la
baleine austral c'est à dire que tout ce
qui dans le monde et identifié comme une
baleine australe net identifier de la
sorte que en comparaison de ce spécimen
donc ça veut dire que c'est le spécimen
le plus important du point de vue
scientifique évidemment du point de vue
de l'espèce il est mort un c'est un
squelette donc c'est pas le plus
important pour l'espèce elle même c'est
le spécimen le plus important du point
de vue scientifique et 7 ce squelette de
baleine australie il lui manque des os
du poignet il lui manque des os du
poignet qui ont très probablement été
volés par des gens peu scrupuleux qui
visitait le musée est par contre un fait
divers tout à fait tout à fait réel là
pour le coup c'est sûr que c'est arrivé
c'est un monsieur qui est arrivé avec
une tronçonneuse et qui a tronçonné le
massacre à la tronçonneuse voilà le
monde 2013
le monde 30 mars 2013 massacre à la
tronçonneuse d'une défense d'éléphant
muséum de paris voilà voilà ce qui
arrive quand on met des spécimens
originaux dans l'est dans les musées
dans l'est dans les expositions des
musées
donc voilà c'est pour ça qu'on les garde
en collection les choses c'est pas pour
cacher un complot aux gens c'est juste
parce que quand on met des trucs
originaux en en exhibition en exposition
bain les gens sont tentés de se ramener
des petits souvenirs
donc voila et par exemple ce gars là bas
il est rentré dans le muséum par
effraction il est allé voir un éléphant
qui datait de l'époque de louis xiv et
il lui a tronçonné une défense voilà
donc non enfin je veux dire l'éléphant
est encore une durée renouvelable
aujourd'hui c'est un c'est quelque chose
que qui se fabriquent encore l'éléphant
de nos jours le dinosaure ça ne se
reproduit plus des dinosaures en tout
cas des tyrannosaures on en a plus
donc quand on en a oui on l'aimé on est
aimé en cachette et on préfère vous
montrer des moulages que vous montrez
des originaux ceci dit si vous tenez à
voir des dinosaures originaux il faut
regarder derrière les vitrines dans les
musées là vous verrez des fossiles
originaux vous ne pourrez pas les
toucher sont derrière une vitre mais
c'est là que vous les trouverez mais par
contre s'il est à portée de main c'est
certain que c'est pas de l'original ça
c'est à peu près sûr donc par exemple si
vous allez je connais pas tous les
musées du monde parker évidemment mais
si vous allez à
à villers sur mer vous verrez des
reptiles marins originaux des squelettes
de reptiles marins originaux si vous
allez à paléo police a pas néopolis pour
le coup je suis sûr qu'ils ont une
mâchoire du tyrannosaure original
derrière une vitrine dans leur
exposition vous pouvez la voir vous ne
pourrez pas la toucher mais vous pourrez
voir et aller complètement original donc
si on montre des spécimens originaux
dans les musées mais par contre ils sont
pas à portée de main ça c'est clair
parce que si on veut si on les laisse à
portée de main ils disparaissent deux
spécialistes en arts visuels et en
sculpture furent promptement embauché
pour inventer un crâne et en partant des
illustrations d'un autre artiste qui
avait représenté un iguanodon donc un
proche parent dadre aux russes donc
jusque là c'est une démarche c'est une
annie one au dos et c'est un proche
parent dadre aux russes donc en partant
de digoine au dos et on va dire de la
spéculation rationnelle c'est sûr que
c'est pas aussi bien que d'avoir un
crâne original mais c'est la spéculation
irrationnelle peut-être à l'époque il
n'avait pas encore de crâne ladrezeau
russe effectivement les deux artistes
dessinèrent la même tête que pour le à
drouot russe foule qui les personnes
impliquées pouvez maintenant défendre
techniquement l'existence de ce
dinosaure banon puisqu'on avait déjà le
reste du squelette bande de baltringues
si quelqu'un posait la question la
combine fonctionne a si bien et du paci
complètement le public qu'ils purent
changer par la suite la tête de la
créature sans que personne ne la
remarque
oui ils purent changer la tête de la
créature quand ils trouvèrent une tête
qui allait avec le corps enfin quand ils
trouvèrent d'autres squelettes dadre aux
russes et des têtes qui qui plus est
allé avec le corps [ __ ] c'est pas les
squelettes complets qui manque d'adressé
aux russes coin la combine fonctionner
sinon à ce jour là drouot russe foule
qui est exposé à l'académie des sciences
naturelles de philadelphie il est dit
que les en semences ont gardé derrière
de lourdes portes closes
pas forcément lourdes portes des racques
je veux dire des brèches mais qu'une
copies en plâtre est présenté à la place
ba oui parce que comme je les dis ça
évite que les gens se barre avec
l'original nous apprenons donc que le
crâne bas niveau n est remplacé à
remplacer d'un iguanodon [ __ ] mais
qu'il est con un iguane au dos par un
iguane tête de
bon bref à remplacer celui d'un
dinosaure exposés l'at on dit au public
à l'époque que nous cache-t-on
aujourd'hui que nous cache-t-on ça y est
enfin
enfin que nous cache-t-on aujourd'hui on
vous cache rien on vous cache rien il
suffit de poser l'équipe les questions
je veux dire ce qu'on ne nous dit pas
c'est que c'est la règle et non
l'exception à ce jour pas à seul
squelette complet de dinosaure n'a été
trouvé faux une fois de plus
là je vous renvoie au début de la vidéo
je veux dire je vais pas je vais pas me
répéter c'est faux on en a trouvé des
millions merci au revoir
même en france on a trouvé des
squelettes complets on veut dire combien
hiatus le combinat tus de france
le conditionner tus de de canjuers
voilà comme sonia tus de canjuers en
france voilà ça c'est le comble sonia
tus de canjuers visible au muséum
d'histoire naturelle je crois que c'est
l'original qui est derrière la vitrine
et c'est un squelette complet de
dinosaures sommes fin octobre et tous
les modèles exposés dans les musées tous
les dessins animés tous les films de
monstres préhistoriques que vous avez pu
voir ne sont que des reconstitutions
imaginaire basé sur des squelettes
accompli un complet à ranger de façon à
les rendre tout à fait réaliste et
crédible aux paléontologues peau faux
faux faux tous les modes en plus c'est
une bien grosse affirmation tous les
modèles exposés dans les musées n'ont
pas tous les modèles exposés dans les
musées comme j'ai dit à des musées qui
expose des originaux de plus il est
communément admis que les squelettes
exhibé dans les musées sont deux sont
tous deux complexes fabrication à base
de plâtre c'est pas des complexes
fabrication c'est des moulages ça veut
dire que c'est des copies des originaux
parce qu'on veut pas mettre les
originaux
à importer de main d apporter des
petites mains indélicates fibre de verre
résine variété et dos d'autres animaux
et non les fossiles d'origine bah oui
mais si tu demande gentiment aux
paléontologues et va t'amener dans les
collections grand con façon propre
dinosaures avec d autres poulets
instruction inratable pour
paléontologues en herbe
ah oui mais là il devait y avoir une
image mais tu as oublié de mettre
l'image quoi j'imagine out of context
quand les oda dinosaures sont préparés
pour être expédiées on utilise des
bandes de toile de jute trempé est pas
dans du plâtre pour les enveloppes et
après l'application préalable d'un tissu
séparateur qui va empêcher un contact
direct avec du plâtre du plâtre avec
l'os en étant les bandes de toile de
jute trempé jusqu'à ce qu'ils sont
entièrement emballé à la manière d'une
momie est prêt pour le transport bon
j'ai rien à dire là-dessus c'est à peu
près comme ça que ça se passe le
transport d'un fossile dans un article
intitulé cieux je vois pas vraiment d'où
sort ce paragraphe est ce qu'il est
censé vouloir dire dans un article
intitulé sur la piste des fossiles de la
fouille à l'exposition un informateur
remarquer à l'aide de moules et de
plâtre nous pouvons intégralement
fabriqué des pâtes des côtes des
vertèbres et cetera pour les éléments
manquants de la structure articulée d'un
squelette le plâtre la fibre de verre et
la résine sont souvent est couramment
utilisé pour un travail de
reconstitution dos simple on peut re
boucher les fissures petites ou grandes
avec du papier mâché ou du plâtre
mélangé à de la dextrine un amidon qui
confère une qualité d'adhésion une
dureté sans plis supplémentaire aux
moules en plâtre habituel nous avons eu
également une bonne réussite avec des
mastics à base de résine
il est possible de sculpter directement
sur place les fragments manquant avec
ces mêmes matériaux en d'autres mots en
gras
attention là je ne sais pas ce que va
être la phrase mais c'est en gras en
d'autres mots le personnel des musées
travaille avec du plâtre et d'autres
matériaux pour transporter est fabriqué
en permanence des squelettes et des
hommes manquant ou incomplets [ __ ] ils
ont ils ont 60 millions d'années connard
ils ont plus de 60 millions d'années ces
ossements évidemment qu'il en manque des
morceaux évidemment qui sont pétés
évidemment qu'il faut lire que les trous
du
q sérieusement non comme des faits catr
trous des culs trous des culs
sérieusement je veux dire c'est des
morceaux manquants de squelettes
incomplet venir on les a les ossements
c'est juste qu'il en manque des morceaux
et que pour les montrer au public
on rajoute les morceaux qui manquent pas
on invente les morceaux qui manque
effectivement ou du moins on s'inspire
des espèces proches comme le cas de la
dhr aux ors et de l'iguane aux dons donc
donc c'est juste pour rendre les choses
regardable je veux dire c'est dieu c'est
de l'esthétique pour le public pour les
paléontologues
on se sert juste des eaux originaux à la
publication la publication scientifique
il ya que les originaux qui sont des
chrétiens les inférences scientifique et
là il ya un gros amalgame là c'est à
dire que vous le mec qui vous racontent
ces conneries là s'imaginent que les
inférences scientifiques sont faits à
partir des modèles qui sont ce qu'ils
sont on va dire pimpé pour être
présentés en exposition non les
inférences scientifiques elles sont
faits à partir du matériel original
allez voir n'importe qu'elle publie
scientifique
ouais d'ivry ya eu jane ou sauveur
bieber vive ria vung voilà pire jay non
c'est non ça a été publiée dans pire jay
voilà que je trouve la publication elle
charge vouvry gaza
dinosaures sauropodes de la famille des
bras qui autorise des qui a été trouvé
en france est décrit par des français
regardent et ronan allain dans la liste
des co-auteurs et donc là je vais vous
montrer c'est juste pour vous montrer
les figures pour vous montrer ce qui est
décrit en vrai dans l'article donc
l'article
il décrit donc l'endroit où on l'a
trouvé voilà les couches géologiques
encore des couches géologiques c'était
certainement un spécimen qui était
connue depuis longtemps donc il a une
grosse histoire donc c'est pour ça lasse
voilà c'est la saint c'est la façon dont
étaient disposées les hô tels qu'ils ont
été trouvés donc évidemment c'est pas
c'est pas la fête à mémé 1 c'est un peu
dans tous les sens mais vous allez voir
que il utilise pas les moules en plâtre
pour pour décrire le spécimen
voilà donc là il montre les dents parce
qu'il ya des dents voilà il montre la
vertèbre qui a été retrouvée vous
n'allez pas me dire qu une vertèbre dans
cet état on l'a inventé quoi vendre de
chez nous qu'il veut dire vous vous
croyez vraiment que si on devait
inventer des vertèbres de dinosaures on
les invente ray écrabouiller comme ça
quoi sérieusement
allez vous faire soigner quoi voilà le
regarder l'état du matériel quoi donc
c'est du beau matériel ça de sas en plus
de 100 millions d'années mais voilà ça
c'est pas du matériel moderne ça ça a
pris dans la gueule ça a pris cher dans
la gueule de me regarder tronche de sept
vertèbres quoi sérieusement
elle est même plus symétrique le dire
regardez là ça dépasse sur le côté là
elle est même plus symétrique vous
croyez vraiment qu'on s'est déformée des
os moderne comme ça non ça c'est de la
tectonique qui a fait ça c'est de la dia
génèse qui a fait ça là le bassin là et
puis vous voyez il n'y a que des
originaux il n'y a pas de plâtre enfin
si celui là regardez il a été reconnu
voilà là la jad mais il ya eu du
racolage on a recollé les morceaux bon
voilà on encore le droit de recoller les
morceaux non dire regardez là là il ya
clairement un morceau qui manquent il a
pas été inventé un celui des reins il
est resté tel quel
là c'est pareil il ya clairement du
morceau qui manquait
ils n'ont pas été inventés donc voilà ça
c'est un mec
je disais tout à l'heure c'est un
connard de gratte papier qui fait ses
recherches sur internet
même pas il fait même pas ses recherches
sur internet parce que s'il avait fait
ses recherches sur internet le connard
de gratte papier il aurait vu que non
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
est ce qu'il ya une reconstruction là
est ce que je me rappelle plus
reconstruction maintenant tu vous voyez
ils font même pas de reconstruction dans
les publicités anti fikin ils font juste
c'est du sauvage et bourrin l'unss et du
sauvage et bourrin de l'anatomie 100 % 1
c'est limite limite ça m'agace mais en
fait ça montre ça démontre bien plus ce
que je veux dire que n'importe quoi
d'autre
ils ont bien fait une petite silhouette
là ils font toujours ça les
paléontologues dinosaures aux log une
petite silhouette où il replace le
fossile au bon endroit à will replace
les fossiles au bon endroit
bah non vous voyez cela ils n'ont même
pas fait donc en plus je me prends avant
je me prends avant quelle autre
moi je sais pas très sain on peut
marquer n'importe quel dinosaures
argentinosaurus tient hop
anon tient on va comprendre un plus
marrant dredd nocus because because they
have no hay 10 à 8 is written voilà là
c'est la bonne orthographe drake note us
est dans la pub lille et présentée de
cette façon la sonde red red lotus c'est
un gros c'est un gros c'est un bon gros
sauropodes à vous pouvez voir un des
plus gros d'ailleurs donc les fossiles
retrouvés ces les fossiles en gris et
puis ben voilà on les remet en place
dans un seul est hypothétique
reconstruit à partir des proches parents
de drague lotus qu'on a retrouvé entier
et dieu sait qu'il y en a donc voilà
donc pas de souci après on peut faire la
titanosaures argent qui n'a le titre
another d'argentine la regarder les mecs
croyez qu'ils ont inventé celui là
croyez vraiment qu'ils les ont inventés
sérieusement ils sont encore là ils sont
même encore dans la couche là croyez
vraiment que les mecs se sont baladés
avec des eaux de cette taille sont allés
creuser des trous enterrer les eaux pour
ensuite revenir et faire quoi au regard
des ondées trouver quelque chose et puis
vous croyez et ça c'est une espèce
moderne sait quelles espèces modernes sa
bande de blue d'abedi d'abda non message
amendes des insultes maintenant c'est
quelles espèces modernes qui a un fémur
de cette taille sérieusement hein vous
pensez qu'ils sont allés le chercher où
ce fémur la non mais bref on continue en
fait il est admis que les expositions
avec d'immenses os de dinosaures qu'on
voit dans les musées du monde
son défaut soigneusement préparé oui
surtout quand les eaux sont immenses la
solution à ton problème est dans ta
question aux connards
surtout quand les eaux sont immenses
camps les eaux sont immenses ils sont
hyper lourd et quand ils sont hyper
lourd on peut pas les déplacer
et encore moins les montées en squelette
entier donc oui on est obligé de faire
des copies qui sont plus légères
l on peut les bouger parce qu'on veut
pas avoir tu peux pas monter une grue à
l'intérieur de la galerie d'amuser
glandus un peu de logique là un peu de
bepc dans ta tête à aucun chercheur
indépendant n'a jamais examiné un vrai
squelette de dinosaure au au fossé déjà
déjà on va définir ce que c'est que
chercheur indépendant
c'est quoi un chercheur indépendant
honnêtement bon c'est juste faux il ya
des tas de il ya des tas de musées dont
le les backstage sont ouverts au public
ils peuvent y aller quand ils veulent et
n'importe qui qui fait la demande aura
accès aux fossiles
oui fait la demande demandé jeudi
reposer la question allait dans le musée
le plus proche de chez vous est demandé
est ce que je peux voir un original je
suis un petit peu sceptique
est ce que je peux voir un original
évidemment commencez pas à les sortir
vos théories à deux francs évidemment
qui va vous regarder en levant les yeux
au ciel mais demander juste à aller voir
les originaux si vous doutez aller dans
n'importe quel musée ils ont forcément
des fossiles bref on prétend que tous
les fossiles réels sont conservés dans
des réserves sous haute sécurité et
c'est pas forcément vrai nom là la haute
sécurité
la haute sécurité c'est bon pour les
fossiles d'hominidés à la limite mais
pop vraiment pour les dinosaures
le vrai problème avec les dinosaures
c'est pas tellement la sécurité c
c'est surtout la place mais seuls
quelques paléontologues choisis sont
autorisés à les examiner
encore une fois c'est parce que t'as pas
demandé le grand public n'a donc aucun
moyen de pour établir leur authenticité
si quand il ya des vrais qui sont
montrés dans les vitrines
mais marc les vitrines si vous voulez le
voir et le toucher va falloir demander
votre foulard falloir à se montrer polis
et courtois
la plupart des gens pensent que les
squelettes de dinosaures exposées dans
les musées sont composés lancement de
dinosaures non c'est du plâtre on sait
bien ce n'est pas le cas les vrais héros
sont enfermés pas dans d'épaisses
chambre forte c'est pas vrai dont les
clés sont détenues par quelques
chercheurs ou placé seulement
non c'est pas les chercheurs qui
détiennent les clés trou de balle
ce sont les gérants des musées
l'écureuil thorn et les responsables de
collection sont pas toujours chercheur
les responsables de collection
d'ailleurs plus souvent ils ne le sont
pas en réalité ce qui veut dire qu'en
cas chercheur indépendant n'a tenu entre
les mains un os de tyrannosaure rex
c'est faux c'est faux en plus du en plus
tu nous a parlé au juste au dessus d'eux
des gens qui vendait des squelettes
entiers de dinosaures ça veut dire qu'il
ya déjà des véritables fossiles qui sont
en circulation en dehors des musées trou
du cul non mais vraiment là je veux dire
le mec au dessus il nous décrit le enfin
le mec la fan je sais pas qui a écrit
l'article original parce que c'est une
traduction d'un autre article mais il
nous dit au dessus qui a des squelettes
en libre circulation la commerce juteux
tout ça tout ça et là il nous dit qu'il
ya aucun chercheur indépendant qui a
détenu entre les mains mais à les
contacter nicolas sked g2 ou dicaprio et
demandez lui de voir ces les dinosaures
qu'il a dans son salon quoi parce que
c'est des vrais qu'ils ont dans leur
salon ces [ __ ] la fin n'ont pas pu
nicolas sketches sont tyrannosaure il a
dû le rendre à la mongolie mais bref je
veux dire si les chercheurs indépendants
ils ont toutes les façons du monde
d'aller voir des vrais faux cils toutes
les opportunités et la raison pour
laquelle tu n'es pas au courant de ce
qu'ils ont pu dire c'est parce que ils
ont découvert qu'en fait c'était des
vrais faux cils et ouais
et découvert que c'était des vrais faux
cils et que leurs théories bullshit ils
pouvaient se les carrer voilà et que
s'il publiait ça eh ben ils allaient
passer pour des cons voilà quand des
personnes non affiliés à l'establishment
paléontologique tente d'accéder à des os
de dinosaure pour les étudier il essuie
refus sur refus preuve
moi je demande une preuve jeu non non
pas refus sur refus seul 2100 low dose
de dinosaures ont été découvertes par le
monde et ce et sur ce nombre seuls
quinze ensembles complets dose de
tyrannosaure ont été découverts seul de
15 ans semble incomplet le tyrannosaure
été découverts donc là on parle de
tyrannosaure parle plus de la dhr aux
russes là parce que 2100 l'autre
dinosaures non il ya quand même plus que
ça de dinosaures qui a été découvert à
2100 c'est un couloir du tailleur du
royal tyrrell museum un bref 15 ans
semble incomplet de tyrannosaurus rex
ont été découverts bas excuse moi pour
une bestiole de 12 mètres de long qui a
vécu il ya 60 millions d'années case
squelette incomplet c'est quand même pas
mal dit dont tu as l'air de dire que
c'est un genre facile quoi c'est le dos
non jamais celle au dos n'ont jamais
formé de squelette complet mais à partir
de ces ensembles de sa complet les
paléontologues ont construit une
hypothèse sur l'apparence du squelette
entier
bah oui tu trouves la moitié du bas tu
trouves la moitié du haut tu fais un
squelette entier de la même espèce
évidemment le jeu dernier voilà non il
n'ya pas deux il n'y a pas de mystère il
n'y a pas de brefs dont il tire un
modèle en plastique si des milliers de
créatures au long cou et de grands
reptiles carnivores avait vraiment
marcher sur terre nous n'aurions pas
trouvé juste 2100 mode ossements mais
des millions avec des gens ordinaires
qui trébuche dessus quand ils baissent
leurs tarifs potager robin coup fed
les dinosaures n'ont jamais existé mort
bat robin coup fait d'espèces de mon
trou du cul préféré visiblement parce
que c'est toi le responsable de tout ça
qui est robin coup fed alors déjà coup
fait
koufos oued robeet couche ou aides ont
mis de coup fourré de twitter dit
benzema mort existait hockey ouais bon
de flat of conspiracy watch
ok donc c'est un jean sergent gens qui
circulent dans les milieux qui pue du
cul ou bingo foued donc monsieur robin
co foued je reviens mais dinosaures je
vais pas commencer à partir sur la terre
plate les dinosaures se trouvent dans
des couches qui date de plus de 60
millions d'années les couches en
question ont été recouvertes par
d'autres couches depuis 60 millions
d'années
il ya 60 millions de cedis d'années de
sédimentation qu'ils leur sont tombées
sur la gueule
depuis donc il s'est passé des choses
d'une part ils ont été enterrées très
profond donc c'est pas partout que qu'il
ya des affleurements d'autre part donc
déjà les affleurements sont très rares
faut attendre qu'il y ait des
déformations delà de la croûte terrestre
pour que l'ale ces couches
réapparaissent à la surface d'une part
d'autre part les fossiles ils ont morflé
ils ont pris 60 millions d'années de
sédimentation dans la gueule et pour
apparaître à la surface faut qu'en plus
il est pris des mouvements tectoniques
dans leur gueule donc non non il n'y a
pas beaucoup de faux cils
évidemment qu'il ya pas beaucoup de
fossiles de tyrannosaurus rex
évidemment qu'il ya plus de matériel
fragmentaire que de matériel non
fragmentaires c'est parce que c'est
parce que c'est parce que baver trouvait
à fossiles ça reste un événement rare et
en plus il faut avoir l'oeil aussi donc
monsieur robin coup fed va te faire
[ __ ]
va te faire [ __ ]
quand des enfants dans un musée de
dinosaures à a maintenant on va
commencer à nous parler des enfants
ils mentent à nos enfants quand des
enfants dans un musée de dinosaures ce
qui est exposé est il de la science ou
de l'art et de la science fiction c'est
souvent un mélange d'un peu tout mais
est ce que je préfère parler plutôt de
spéculation rationnelle parce que
présenter les faits et seulement les
faits les gens ça les emmerde surtout
les enfants donc il faut évidemment
faire un petit enrobage de un petit
enrobage de fiction histoire que que la
sauce prenne
voilà mes spéculations rationnelle quoi
sommes nous tromper et avant new subi
dès notre enfance
un lavage à lavage de cerveau quoi on
vous parle de dinosaures vous vous
parlez d'un lavage de cerveau ne faisant
croire au mythe des leaders il est
nécessaire de poser les questions
pointues sur toute cette affaire de
dinosaures qu est ce qu on croit qu'on
veut qu'ils veulent qu'on sache non mais
après la question est intéressante c'est
comme en conseil comme en concert qu'on
croise qu'on sache non comment qu'on
sache ce qu'on croit conseil voilà donc
la question posée derrière elle et pas
si mal finalement c'est comment
conseiller ce qu'on croit qu'on sache
bas au bout d'un moment il faut il faut
pas chercher sur internet vous demandez
aux spécialistes si vraiment tu crois
qu'il ya un complot des spécialistes il
ya qu'en allant interroger les
spécialistes que tu ne sauras mec meuf
ou à l'erreur il a fallu l'apport
constant depuis les premières
découvertes de dinosaures d'un
assortiment dose de divers animaux comme
des crocodiles et alligators des iguanes
de 12 m de long 1 évidemment des iguanes
avec des fémurs plus grand qu'un homme
girafes éléphants move un kangourou
n'est mien pour fabriquer et créé le
concept artificiel awa thiam et baleines
devrait donc un fémur de baleines idée
fémur de baleines
bien sûr un os de la jambe d'une baleine
mais bien sûr pour fabriquer et créé le
concept artificielle nouveau dan animal
préhistorique appelé dinosaures c'est
pas un animal des dinosaures [ __ ]
fermez vos gueules way to à tous ceux
aussi qui disent le dinosaure et
l'espèce dominante le dinosaure c'est
pas une espèce un tyrannosaurus rex
c'est une espèce de dinosaure les
dinosaures c'est des milliers d'espèces
quoi il y en a dix mille qui vivent
encore aujourd'hui c'est les oiseaux
donc les dinosaures c'est des milliers
des milliers d'espèces c'est pas une
espèce dominante
quand les os d'animaux existants ne
trompe pas suffisamment il
on va fabriquer utiliser des substituts
en plâtre
donc on part d'une complétion de
squelettes incomplet à des substituts
voilà une tromperie mais bien sûr des
matériaux qui ressemble à la place à une
pâte à modeler en argile ou en plâtre
feront la faire on peut employer aussi
des moules
quelle serait la motivation d'un
téléphone de supercherie ah oui ça je
suis d'accord ouais ouais quelles
seraient les ford à quelle serait la
motivation d'un tel effort de
supercherie parce que bordel le pouvoir
ah oui le pouvoir
mais oui mais oui le pouvoir les
paléontologues du domine le monde mais
bien sur des ouï le pouvoir évidemment
évidemment mais oui alors attendez je
vais aller retrouver sur le facebook de
stop science parce qu'il ya un article
intéressant qui est sorti sur le
facebook de stop science on a partagé
une un article qui est paru dans le
monde cette année donc 2018
bon je dis ça au cas où la vidéo est
encore là dans mille ans on a partagé un
article sur du monde où justement la
patiente le où il est décrit qu'en gros
là par les anthologies en france est en
train de crever mais littéralement il ya
un mec
enfin y'a pas un mec qui est un grand
professeur excusez-moi professeur
abderrazak el albani que nous avons eu
le plaisir d'interviewer d'ailleurs sur
cette option qui a découvert les
premières formes de vie multicellulaires
vieille de 2 milliards d'années un truc
qui réécrit littéralement l'histoire de
la profession on va dire enfin qui
réécrit l'histoire de l'origine de la
vie multicellulaire en tout cas et ce
professeur abderrazak el albani se
voient refuser depuis dix ans des fonds
par le gouvernement français
donc vous allez me dire ou es le complot
l'a expliqué moi ou elle complot en tout
cas si les s'il ya complot il n'est pas
de notre côté ça c'est sûr on fait on
fait certainement pas ça pour le pouvoir
parce que de toute façon je veux dire le
premier curé venu fait plus d'entrées
dans son église que le que les
paléontologues alors conférence excusez
moi hein
il ya quand même plus de gens qui il ya
encore plus de gens qui vont à l'église
ou à la mosquée que de gens qui vont
dans les conférences de paléontologues
bon et on fait certainement pas ça non
plus pour l'argent
parce que voyez on en a plus d'études
même pour les gens comme abderrazak el
albani qui ont fait la couverture de
genre le nature's c'est la revue la plus
prestigieuse du monde voilà nature's
c'est c'est le times pour les
paléontologues je veux dire c'est au
graal donc voilà donc si c'est pas
l'argent et pouvoir base il pose la
question 1
quelles seraient les motivations d'un
tel effort je sais pas je vois pas
d'évidence motivation font référence à
une tentative de prouver la théorie de
l'évolution
non pas avec encore une fois pas avec
les dinosaures
certainement pas avec les dinosaures il
ya des fossiles de foraminifères les
fossiles de foraminifères et de rongeurs
démontre bien mieux la théorie de
l'évolution que ceux des dinosaures donc
non de réfuter ou de jeter le doute sur
la bible chrétienne et l'existence de
dieu à saillé le complot des le complot
des dévots le complot des fous de dieu
ça y est on y vient de réfuter ou de
jeter donc le doute sur la bible
chrétienne et l'existence de dieu non
l'existence des dinosaures ne réfute pas
l'existence de dieu
enfin si vous pensez que le dieu a créé
la vie je vois pas pourquoi ils
n'auraient pas créé les dinosaures des
chrétiens et de réfuter la théorie de la
terre jeunes bas idem je connait enfin
je veux dire il ya suffisamment de sites
sur internet qui défendent la théorie de
la terre jeunes et qu'ils acceptent
totalement l'existence des dinosaures la
théorie de la terre jeunes n'est pas
vraiment une théorie d'ailleurs la
spéculation complètement dingue de la
terre jeunes la spéculation complètement
dingue de la terre jeune peut très bien
s'accommoder de l'existence des
dinosaures il suffit d'admettre que les
dinosaures n'ont pas des millions
d'années ils ont juste 15 ans la suffit
d'admettre que ma grand-mère chevaucher
des dinosaures
et puis voilà peut-être pas ma grand
mère mon arrière grand mère parce que ma
grand mère je lui ai demandé l a jamais
chevauchée de dinosaures mais peut-être
qu'elle fait partie du complot qui sait
à le concept de dinosaures implique que
si dieu existe il a bricolé son idée de
dinosaures pendant un moment puis l'a
probablement écarter ou s'est fatigué de
cette création est a poursuivi en créant
l'homme la chronologie historique des
dinosaures présente présenter suggère un
dieu un parfait qui s'est présentée
après coup qui s'est présentée après
coup l'idée de l'homme reléguant ainsi
l'idée biblique de dieu ayant créé
l'homme à son image non bah non puisque
si dieu est imparfait qu'il a créé
l'homme à son image bah voila il a créé
un homme imparfait
tout va bien je vois pas le problème je
veux dire
toute façon le enfin là pour le coup on
parle du dieu des chrétiens le dieu des
chrétiens il est imparfait impasse que
le dieu des chrétiens il est censé être
il est censé tout savoir savoir tout
faire il est censé tous avoir passé
présent futur savoir tout faire et être
infiniment bon il ya un truc qui
s'appelle la seconde guerre mondiale
désolé d'atteindre le point godwin voilà
ça j'ai tenu j'ai tenu j'ai dû tenir une
heure même pas désolé d'atteindre le
point godwin mais si vous pensez à la
seconde guerre mondiale il ya forcément
une de ces choses qui est fausse soit
ils savaient et dans ce cas là il n'est
pas infiniment bon soit il ne savait pas
et dans ce cas là il est il ne sait pas
tout soit il n'a il savait et il est
infiniment bon mais il n'a rien pu faire
donc bah voilà donc le dieu des
chrétiens je suis désolé et voilà après
honnêtement je suis chrétien donc je
veux dire mais bon j'ai conscience des
limites des paroles de la bible on a le
droit d'être chrétien est d'être
conscient des limites des paroles de la
bible
donc pour le coup non c'est pas les
dinosaures la meilleure arme pour
réfuter l'idée de dieu 1 la meilleure
arme pour réfuter l'idée de dieu sait
quand même c'est quand même le point
godwin
bref taper squelette de dinosaure dans
un moteur de recherche et vous trouverez
une variété de répliques de dinosaures
fait sur mesure et de squelettes de
qualité musée squelettes de dinosaures
voilà je tape squelettes de dinosaures
donc on a effectivement des squelettes
de qualité muséale n'y a pas de souci
mais alors on a surtout cette merde là
cette mer de là un dinosaure encore dans
son plâtre pas du tout préparés bref à
dinosaures tel qu'on le trouve sur le
terrain est telle qu'il a été ramenée
empaqueté dans son petit plâtre 1
donc ça c'est pas un squelette qualité
musée ça en plus celui là je les ai vus
en vrai squelette squelette secrète de
royal multihiv and museum
hop je vous retrouve l'endroit parce que
je les ai vus en vrai dans les backstage
celui là et regardez là le petit crâne
là qui ressort là cette petite tête là
c'est ça il ya la petite tête qui
ressort les côtes web on s'est peut-être
pas exactement le même parce que
maintenant je vois qu'il est pas
exactement de la même couleur mais bon
voilà c'est la même idée quoi c'est un
petit tyrannosaure ou un petit carnivore
un petits théropodes puis voilà ça c'est
l'état de merde dans lesquelles on les
trouve quoi il ya encore ça c'est un
superbe squelette articulé
encore une fois on trouve des squelette
articulé un l'un des plus grands et des
plus renommés fournisseur de faux
dinosaures et la société zynga gong dino
ocean art au sichuan en chine
ouais bah alors là même les
paléontologues savent que la chine ses
plus grands fournisseurs de defaud
dinosaures du monde à l'histoire de
l'archéo raptor l'a bien montré c'est
que même les paléontologues se sont fait
avoir mais ceci dit depuis l'histoire de
l'archéo raptor maintenant tous les
fossiles chinois ou presque avant d'être
publiées faut qu'ils soient scannés et
analysés pour détecter les fraudes
1 et d'ailleurs je tiens à dire que
l'histoire de l'archéo raptor
comme l'histoire d'ailleurs de l'homme
de piles donne donc l'histoire des
fossiles elles n'ont pas été débarqué
par des chercheurs de vérité l ombre
elles n'ont pas non plus été débarqué
par des créationnistes c'est d'autre
paléontologues qui les ont des bonnes
pièces et histoire dans le cas de la
dans le cas de l'homme de piltdown c'est
le gros clark qui était un paléo
anthropologues renommer qui a découvert
la supercherie et c'était pas un
créationniste
et dans le cas de l'archéo raptor c'est
timothy roe de l'université du texas si
je ne me trompe pas de l'université
d'austin au texas qui a des bonnes
quelle histoire de l'archéo raptor est
pareil c'est un grand paléontologues
tout à fait reconnu dans le métier donc
voilà les des bunkers c'est pas les
c'est pas les chercheurs de vérité les
des bunkers c'est les scientifiques donc
les scientifiques font des erreurs mais
les scientifiques se corrige haute aux
collectivités de la science beach de
chine qui ravitaillent les musées
d'histoire naturelle partout dans le
monde avec des squelettes ultra réaliste
de dinosaures fabriqués à partir de vos
réseaux bah ça comme je les dis oui
effectivement il ya un marché juteux en
chine de faux de faux de faux partiel on
va dire le dernier d'ailleurs c'est le
dinosaure signe comment il s'appelle un
nouveau dinosaure à cou de cygne
al ce cas raptor voilà alsc à raptor
dont le fossile et dont le fossile a été
jugée par beaucoup de paléontologues
comme étant un peu trop beau pour être
vrai voilà donc là le ski à ce qui a mis
la puce à l'oreille des gens c'est un
peu la patine qui a autour là ouais
voilà il est un peu trop beau pour être
vrai donc et je veux dire il ya fallu
deux jours il a fallu deux jours pour
que les gens regardent le fossile et 10
il ya un truc louche un chai celui-là
donc quand à fos il a l'air louche on le
voit après celui là ça n'a pas encore
été démontrée on sait pas encore si
c'est un vrai un fossé encore débattue
mais voilà je veux dire quand il ya un
truc qui pue du cul
eh bien c'est dit 1 je veux dire c'est
il est dit il est dit et répété avec
voilà il faut se méfier oui messieurs
dames
surtout que celui là il a une origine
qui est connu pour être douteuse là pour
le coup il a on connaît le fournisseur
qui est la france est d'ailleurs et ce à
un fournisseur qui a déjà une réputation
pour avoir fourni de faux fossiles en
provenance de chine et de mongolie donc
là voilà de bons jeux rien de plus à
dire il ya une part de vérité là dedans
il ya définitivement une part de vérité
c'est comme mais encore une fois c'est
pas les musées il ravitaille c'est en
plus il le dit lui même il ravitaille
les musées donc ccd privés qui trouvent
des fossiles les assemble pour faire
défaut et après les vendent aux musées
donc les musées sont la victime
les mulets les musées sont laissons les
victimes de ces deux c'est faux son
palais et au final si on démontre qu'un
fossile comme alsa raptor allez-y raptor
whatever est un faux et ben c'est le
musée qui va en pâtir et sa réputation
va prendre un sacré coup et je peux vous
dire que l'histoire de l'art qui ont
rapport il ya deux paléontologues qui
doivent encore être en train de bouffer
leurs chaussures à leurs pieds et de
s'en mordre les doigts de pied du coup
en dessous
bref des autres poulets de grenouilles
de chiens de chats doit voilà du cheval
de huit mètres de haut mélanger avec de
la colle de la résine du plâtre pu
utiliser un matériel aena pour
renouveler des autres dinosaures
je commence à en avoir marre c'est pour
ça que je quitte un peu les phrases on
leur fait même subir des fractures
intentionnel et on leur donne un aspect
ancien fossilisés pour faire apparaître
pour les faire paraître réel oui mais
encore une fois comment tu déforme les
fossiles de la façon dont ils sont
déformés tête de chou nuque
regardez le crâne de sioux le crâne ce
qu'elle sio tyrannosaure parce que sinon
on va avoir
le crâne d'une femme qui s'appelle sion
veut dire regardez le crâne de sioux ça
c'est pas le crâne dessous le vrai crâne
de sioux il est où ça c'est stan va
regarder ça regardez la gueule qu'il a
regardé le nez comme il est le nez comme
il est dévié sur le côté je veux dire
c'est à moins que vous sachiez faire
fondre l'os
il n'y a aucun moyen de faire ça à part
la dia génèse à part la déformations
induites à grande profondeur dans la
roche aucun moyen aucun moyen regarder
celle là elle est encore mieux elle a
regardé comme il est déformé ce crâne
dire à moins d'un moins que le mec qui a
écrit cet article connaissent une
technique qui permet de faire fondre les
hommes modernes n'ont pas comment on
arrive à faire ça à part un processus de
fossilisation et de dia génère donc aux
chiottes
on leur fait même subir des fractures et
un il s'en vante même sur leur website
plus de 62 % de notre production part
sur les marchés américain et européen ce
qui veut dire que nous sommes au courant
des complexités des règlements
d'exportations vers ces pays
comme nous sommes partenaires des musées
de dinosaures tous les produits sont
fabriqués sur la direction d'espère de
l'académie des sciences chinoise
nous bénéficions d'un réseau mondial de
vente touchant des pays comme les usa le
brésil la france la pologne à un cinéma
etc et nos produits sont exposés au
pérou en argentine à vancouver
cincinnati chicago et d'autres endroits
encore une fois c'est pour les
expositions c'est clairement écrit que
c'est pour les expositions d'ailleurs je
suis sûr que on va aller taper teasing
zing d'ondine ocean art
ce que je peux faire un copier coller
zeego ocean art
est-ce qu'on peut aller sur le site
animatroniques dinosaures simulation bas
va là bas tout est là c'est des trucs
qui sont faits pour les attend il ya
même pas de squelettes en réalité à s'il
ya des squelettes ya quand même des
répliques de squelette autant pour moi
c'est pas parce que ça j'allais dire
c'est pas des squelettes a donc les
squelettes damas quand même pas mal
quand même brûlé ce qu'il est lassé du
fait qu'elle est effectivement enfin en
même temps je veux dire
y'a pas à tortiller du cul que ces
squelettes l'oeil sont fait qu
évidemment
évidemment qu'ils sont fake enfin je
veux dire ça se voit à quoi bon aller
peut-être celui-là il ay sens un peu
mieux le réalisme mais en même temps et
c'est écrit dessus je veux dire c'est
des répliques à celle écrire réplique ah
c'est pas écrit que c'est des vrais donc
oui c'est fait pour les expositions
c'est fait pour montrer aux gens des
choses qui sont regardables évidemment
qu'on va pas vous montrer les merdes
dans l'état où on les trouve
je vous imaginait pas la gueule que ça
aurait sinon amusé ce serait triste à
mourir
donc heureusement qu'on vous montre des
choses qui sont regardables cola j'ai
entendu dire qu'il existe une usine de
faux faux cils au nord-est de la chine
mais non c'est pas une usine de faux
faux cils c'est une usine de répliques
de fossiles dans la province du liaoning
près du dépôt on aurait trouvé les
supposés récent dinosaures à plumes ou
oui certainement parce que l'usiné de
fos par l usine de répliques de fossiles
en question s'est bâtie autour d'un
gisement qui existe réellement afin de
faire sa promo et aussi parce que c'est
là que le marché se trouve peut-être
qu'il y a même amusé juste à côté du
conte la possibilité existe que da
portant alan fédou kyats professeur de
paléontologie
ou alors ça ça demande vérification
parce que ça me dit rien c'est duch ya
c'est un pas les ornithologistes presse
spécialisée dans l'origine des oiseaux
professeur émérite de caroline du nord
qu'est ce qu'il a écrit éducation
majorité 91 qui en nicotine existait
donc c'est un ornithologue enfin il dit
ils disent pas les ornithologues mais
bon c'est plus un ornithologue qui à
paléo
qu un paléontologue quelque chose soit
claire
bref admettons bon bah il a dit qu'il ya
un truc qui s'est construit bon il a dit
qu'il ya un musée qui s'est construit
dans l'ironie c'est bien la possibilité
existe que d'importants aux deux
dinosaures exposés étaient et modifier
artificiellement par sculptures et
gravures sculpter des eaux n'est pas une
activité inconnu de l'homme de
nombreuses cultures ont pris part à la
création d'objets d'artificiel et 2 à
partir d'eau existants totalement
impossible à différencier de l'original
totalement impossible est différent si
l'original suffit de couper et puis tu
verras qu'à l'intérieur c'est pas du
vrai je veux dire le coupé le scanner
même d'ailleurs tu peux faire un scanner
à rayons x tu vois à travers mais même
une radio à ça se voit l'industrie du
dinosaure et l clientes de ce genre de
trafic
bah oui l'industrie du dinosaure pas là
pas la science la science en est victime
et éventuellement mais pas cliente est
il possible que la réplique d'un
squelette de dinosaure soit reconstitué
au fabriquer secrètement non c'est pas
secrètement ils ont un site internet du
conte dans des bâtiments privés
loin de la vue du public avec des eaux
fabriquer artificiellement utilisé à
partir de plusieurs d'animaux nés ligne
pourquoi s'embêter à posséder des
fossiles originaux et authentiques quand
des supposés réplique plaisent au public
ben c'est surtout pourquoi s'emmerder à
montrer des fossiles originaux qui sont
pas spécialement esthétique est plutôt
fragile extrêmement lourd et qui risque
de se faire voler alors qu'on peut
montrer des répliques des répliques
fidèles un de qualité scientifique
fuck you un autre problème avec les
dinosaures est leur dynamique
structurelle non naturelle pour cheat
ça sent la phrase puis qui veut rien
dire tu sais excusez-moi j'ai éteint mon
navigateur par accident pendant que la
vidéo pendant que la vidéo s'enregistrer
donc il ya un petit décalage mais voilà
ça devrait pas poser de majeur problème
à votre compréhension de ce qui se passe
donc un autre problème avec les
dinosaures et leur dynamique
structurelle non naturelle donc on
à travers cette phrase qui veut pas dire
grand chose dans l'absolu on sent bien
que l'idée qui transparaissent et qu'en
gros les dinosaures sont une
impossibilité biologiques parce qu'ils
sont trop gros du moins j'imagine que
c'est là qu'ils vont se diriger
bon on entre par anticipation un
évidement voilà comme sonia tus
non parce que j'aime autant prendre les
devants tu vois je m'entends prendre les
devants donc le consomme ignatus je vais
même préciser celui de canjuers
puisqu'on a dû concerner que tu vis en
france
c'est formidable le comme sonia tu sais
ce qu'on a une petite petite image à
l'échelle d'un copieux natus voilà vous
les voyez dans jurassic park cdma chat
il nous arrive à la cheville même pas
donc celui de canjuers c'est le orange
voilà vous pouvez voir que c'est pas un
spa un gros bide eu l'astuce donc
impossibilité biologique éventuellement
pour les plus gros pourquoi pas tout cas
tous les dinosaures ne sont pas des
impossibilités beau biologique [ __ ] de
nombreux squelettes des reconstitutions
de dinosaures présente des monstres
bipèdes comme le t-rex avec un tronc qui
penche vers l'avant et une tête bien
plus grosse lourde que le contrepoids
donné par la queue bah oui sur le
squelette oui mais une fois que tu
rajoutes la viande par dessus la queue
elle avait tellement muscles que que se
contrebalancer très bien et en plus la
tête et les vertèbres cervicales et
l'autre ont d'ailleurs aussi chez le
tyrannosaure avait des sacs aérien comme
chez les oiseaux on peut le voir sur
l'os il ya des fausses sur les vertèbres
qui montrent qu'ils avaient des cinq
aérien
donc bien que massive la partie
antérieure la partie avant du
tyrannosaure n'était pas aussi lourdes
que sa famille ou de nombreux modèles
exposés dans les musées ne peuvent même
pas tenir debout à cause de leur propre
poids que d'armes sérieusement est-ce
que ce qu'il ya vraiment des gens qui
ont avalé ça
raison pour laquelle à squelettes ne
tient pas debout tout seul c'est parce
qu'il est un squelette
ça marche aussi avec un être humain
pourtant on existe bien le dire on
existe ou vie on respire mais quand on
est des squelettes on tient plus debout
tout seul c'est étonnant si franchement
étonnant ça doit être un complot il est
hautement improbable que des bêtes aussi
énorme est disproportionnée et puis
jamais existé bon ben voilà on y vient
l'argument de la taille
ce pour lequel je serai globalement
d'accord puisque l'arrêt enfin
comprendre comment des bestioles comme
les sauropodes ont pu devenir aussi
grosse est toujours une question une
question très hautement discuter ceci
dit j'ai fait une vidéo qui en parle
j'ai fait une vidéo qui en parlent donc
je vais devoir retourner sur youtube
parce que tous ces états mais voilà stop
science peser un dinosaure voilà j'ai
oublié de mettre le tout cannes afin
donc déjà on a fait une vidéo qui
s'appelle le plus gros dinosaures sur
comment on estime le point là dinosaures
ce qui est un ski est une question
importante quand il s'agit de déterminer
si oui ou non les dinosaures sont des
choses naturellement possible ou pas
donc je crois que c'était peser un
tyrannosaure là le titre de la vidéo
voilà science diffuse peser le
tyrannosaure ou godzilla à la maison
donc vous pouvez aller la voir ça ne
mange pas de pas et vous apprendrez les
choses sur comment on fait pour estimer
la masse dinosaures et pourquoi les
dinosaures et comment les dinosaures ont
fait pour être aussi gros bref il est
hautement improbable que les bêtes aussi
énorme est disproportionnée et plus
jamais existé la charge
agissant sur leur squelette est si forte
que des calculs indiquent que les eaux
des plus grands dinosaures se
déformerait et se fissure version sous
leur propre poids
oui encore une fois tout dépend du poids
pour un brachiosaure ça va de 100 tonnes
à 13 tonnes
donc on sait même pas déjà combien il
pesait de base donc sous leur énorme
poids 13 tonnes c'est le point d'un
éléphant enfin non pardon brachiosaures
russe il ya eu au moins une estimation
de masse je vais reprendre les choses
depuis le début parce que
je l'aï un peu vite brachiosaures us il
ya eu au moins une estimation de sa
masse corporelle qui a estimé son poids
aussi bas que 13 tonnes 13 tonnes c'est
le c'est juste une tonne de plus que le
poids du plus gros éléphant jamais
abattu voilà le plus gros mâle éléphants
qu'on ait abattu faisait 12 tonnes ça
veut pas dire qu'il en a pas des plus
gros qui ont vécu mais celui qu'on a
abattu il faisait 12 tonnes donc voilà
c'est juste une tonne de plus qu'un
éléphant il n'y a pas d'impossibilité
biologique derrière ça mais encore une
fois encore faudrait-il avoir une idée
du poids de ces dinosaures donc jusqu'à
présent voilà on s'accorde que le plus
gros dinosaures argentinosaurus devait
faire autour de 70 tonnes et pour autant
qu on pour autant que j'ai pu en lire la
littérature et j'en ai lu beaucoup ça
reste ça reste correct vu la taille de
ses jambes de la taille de ses guiboles
ça marche
et encore une fois les les sauropodes
eux aussi avaient des sacs aérien dont
il était beaucoup plus légers qu'ils en
ont l'air massif en apparence mais léger
à l'intérieur et on est des experts ont
aussi souligné que les dinosaures
devaient marcher bien plus lentement que
ce qu'on montre dans les films pour
éviter des chocs brusque à leur
squelette
oui bah ça ne ce n'est pas ça ne fait
pas d'eux des impossibilités biologique
cette idée d'animaux se déplaçant
lentement ne colle pas avec l'analyse
biomécanique des dinosaures qui indique
qu'ils étaient agile et d'âge il est
actif créatures ben faut savoir tu
défends kelly des mecs c'est un paradoxe
entre la taille le mode de vie des
dinosaures de nombreuses représentations
et dessins se révèle absurde en montrant
à l'animal à deux pattes qui serait en
total déséquilibre avec le poids de la
tête et de l'abdomen
bien plus élevé que celui de la que
supposé agir comme contrepoids bas à
auchy enfin encore une fois ça dépend de
la quantité de viande que tu y mets sur
la queue mais j'ai envie de dire que la
raison pour laquelle vous marchez bande
de bipèdes bombe d'êtres humains bipèdes
c'est précisément le déséquilibre que
vous porter vers l'avant de votre corps
nous marchons précisément parce que nous
sommes en déséquilibre donc
allez vous faire [ __ ] l'industrie du
dinosaure et elle le cas d'une science
essayant d'aller au devant des désirs ou
des attentes du public au haut cette
phrase est tellement laide l'industrie
du dinosaure était le cas d'une science
m
là tu là là il se révèle derrière leurs
masques dégueulasse là les auteurs de
cet article
ils confondent complètement l'industrie
du dinosaure effectivement donc les
jouets les mulets pas les jouets les
musées les jouets les les films les tout
ça avec la science qui va dont il
s'inspire alors qu'il n'y a aucun [ __ ]
de rapports aucun à part peut-être les
musées justement là j'en viens au musée
à part peut-être les musées qui essaye
un peu de connecter les deux en mettant
ça dépend les musées après il ya des
musées qui met beaucoup de science et -2
et moins de bling bling comme le muséum
d'histoire naturelle à paris et il ya
des musées qui met beaucoup de bling
mais il ya beaucoup moins de sciences il
ya des musées même qui met tout sur le
qui mise tout sur le bling bling avec
juste un tout petit peu d'informations
mais bon bah à part dans les musées je
veux dire il n'y a pas de y'a pas
vraiment ne pas d'interconnexion un
julien encore une fois trouvé moi
trouvez moi une université à laboratoire
de paléontologie qui vont déjouer puis
plus de dinosaures quoi et là
éventuellement je commencerai à vous
prendre au sérieux ça veut pas dire que
vous m'aurez convaincu mais je
commencerai à vous prendre au sérieux
là pour l'instant vous me décevez de
ligne en ligne me faut dire que vous
partiez pas de bien au donc de toutes
façons le film jurassic park parc montre
l'exemple de dinosaures beaucoup plus
grand que toutes les représentations
actuelles des musées non pas pour
tyrannosaure n'ont ni pour le
brachiosaure seulement pour le
velociraptor après la sortie du film il
est intéressant de noter que de nombreux
articles ont été écrits demandant ceci
est il possible
je me souviens d'un rapport sur l'adn de
dinosaures retrouvait préserver dans
l'ombre qui s'est avéré être un faux par
la suite bas de l'adn préserver dans
l'embrouillé effectivement un article
qui est sorti qui avaient montré qu'ils
avaient de l'adn préserver dans l'ombre
dont on a montré que finalement c'était
de l'adn bactérien
voilà et d'ailleurs c'était pas de l'adn
de dinosaures retrouver dans l'ordre on
n'a jamais retrouvé de 10 noeuds de
restes de dinosaures retrouver dans
l'amp en tout cas pas à l'époque de
jurassic park depuis on a trouvé des
cette fameuse que de dinosaures pas
cette longue queue avec des plumes qu'on
suppose être une queue de dinosaures
encore une fois jeudi en voilà deux
dinosaures non aviens mais bon c'est la
seule restes de dinosaures à ma
connaissance retrouver préserver dans
l'ombre de dinosaures à 100% et c'est
certainement pas là dessus que l'analyse
adn dont ils parlent a été extrait donc
éventuellement oui on a oui on a
retrouvé de l'adn dans de l'ambré
c'était de l'adn bactérien plusieurs
millions de dollars ont été mondialement
dépensés pour promouvoir depuis de toute
façon là où il veut en venir c'est qu'en
gros
dtc de nous convaincre de quoi que
jurassic park l'histoire était pas je
veux dire si tu essaies de me convaincre
que l'histoire de jurassic park était
pas vrai j'étais au courant que c'était
un film mec
j'étais au courant est-ce qu est-ce que
je racing part que c'est possible d'un
an qu'un arsenal c'est écrit dessus
plusieurs millions de dollars ont été
mondialement dépensés pour promouvoir
l'existence de dinosaures à travers des
films des émissions de télé des
magazines et des bandes dessinées oui
mais qui qui investit des millions de
dollars warner brothers la twenty
century fox walt disney n'ont rien à
voir avec les universités et les musées
rien du tout le monde du cinéma et de la
paléontologie marche la main dans la
main comme l'a démontré jurassique world
exactement jurassique web qui a fait un
flop monumental à toutes les découvertes
paléontologiques fait depuis les années
90 notamment mettant aucune plume sur
leurs [ __ ] de dinosaures entre autres
mais maintenant vous allez me dire que
le monde du cinéma de la paléontologie
marchent main dans la main y'a jamais il
n'y a jamais que jack horner qui a été
consultant sur jurassic park et jurassic
ou ailleurs donc éventuellement déjà
corner marchent main dans la main avec
le monde du cinéma
éventuellement mais sinon c'est tout
quoi
je veux dire pour avoir été pour avoir
été contacté plusieurs fois par la
presse ou des trucs de documentaires etc
vous dira pas le cinéma des
documentaires je dire déjà les
documentaires on leur dit des trucs qui
veulent pas nous écouter quoi déjà on
leur raconte l'histoire telle qu'elle
s'est telle qu'on pense qu'elle s'est
produite
et eux ils racontent l'histoire telle
que les gens auront envie de l'entendre
aller voir leur de la critique que j'ai
fait du reportage premier homme quoi
déjà un documentaire c'est moche ils
n'ont pas écouté la pascal picq il a été
pascal picq il a été conseiller je suis
sûr qu'ils ont pas écouté un tiers de ce
qu'ils adulent art de ce qu'ils ont dû
leur dire ce qu'il a dû leur dire donc
non à l'arrêt et là on parle de
documentaires on parle pas du cinéma
donc non le
non hollywood ne marche pas mal dans la
main avec avec la paléontologue à part
peut-être jack horner vue la vision des
gens sur l'existence des dinosaures se
base non pas sur des preuves formelles
mais sur les impressions artistiques
fixé par hollywood
alors ça éventuellement je veux bien je
veux bien croire que la vision des gens
la vision que les gens ou des dinosaures
et plus modelé par hollywood que par que
parnes la façon dont on remue les bras
dans le vide
nous autres chercheurs effectivement des
documentaires illustre de manière
éclatante les caractéristiques de chaque
dinosaures comme leur couleur leur poids
et leur masse musculaire mais donne les
cem conseiller pour jurassic park admet
que cela relève de pure supposition
envisager par exemple la question du
poids de ces dinosaures dans les samedis
les scientifiques ne savent pas quel
poids faisait les dinosaures
oui on sait peu de choses sur des
animaux qui n'existe plus oui merci de
l'information encore une fois les
dinosaures sont présentés au public sous
la forme de reconstitution artistique
coloré de dessins de modèles de
gigantesque squelette de musée où ils
sont présentés au public
de cette façon pas à la communauté
scientifique de dessins animés de films
montrant ses bêtes en détails explicites
mais tout comme les nombreuses espèces
supposé d'hommes singes et vas-y les
hommes ça joue là le raccourci
dégueulasse qui pue kkp but toutes les
reconstitutions de dinosaures sont des
fabrications 100% fictives ont la
conclusion qui put alors qu'au dessus
ils disaient qu'on fabriquait les
dinosaures avec des vrais morceaux de
dinosaures maintenant maintenant il dit
que c'est 100% fictifs
et puis les espèces supposé d'hommes
singes pas encore une fois sortir les
doigts du cul et va les voir
voilà je veux dire néandertal
il y en a partout en france des
squelettes de néandertal même dans des
tout petits musées dans des endroits
bien cryptic va voir à ce que l'aide de
néandertal tu verras qui sont 100% vrai
et que le bourrelet sus orbitaire au
dessus des yeux
qui est qui est à caractère on ne peut
plus simiesque est bel et bien là et tu
verras que l'absence de menton qui est
aussi un caractère simiesque est bel et
bien là et tu verra aussi que le volume
crânien qui est très très gros et qui
donc relie néandertal aux humains
modernes
il est là aussi donc voila tu verras que
néandertal est un patchwork entre entre
des caractères humains modernes et des
caractères de singe et a pas besoin
d'aller loin encore une fois au kg où il
présente
mais nenê n'a donc tous les
reconstituent toute la reconstitution de
dinosaures sont des fabrications 100%
fictif créé par des évolutionnistes
intéressés et d un antijeu vouera le
complot des évolutionnistes pour dominer
le monde pour avoir du pouvoir et gagner
beaucoup d'argent comme je le disais
tout à l'heure mais oui il présenta des
ca des noms mais c'est vrai franchement
les évolutionnistes on a tellement plus
d'influencé que le pape
on a tellement d' influence sur le monde
comparé au pop et de pognon il présente
à dessein des dinosaures aux enfants
dans les médias pour exciter leur jeune
l'imagination et les influences et vers
leurs combines
oui parce que les religions font pas ça
maintenant les religions sont gentils
les religions font pas ça non mais là je
me place dans un contexte d'opposition
entre évolutionniste et religieux mais
c'est lui qui l'a fait avant ça c'est
l'auteur de ce torchon qui l'a fait
avant donc je joue son jeu au final
mais oui bien sûr oui on vernon combine
nos copines qui consiste à vous
extorquer de l'argent
mais oui bien sûr des dessins animés
comme l'âge de glace et le petit
dinosaure est la vallée des merveilles
les filles comme je les filme comme
jurassic park et dinosaures hayden les
livres poupées jouets en plastique
manuels scolaires et primaire et
représentations dans les musées sont
tannés fait certain sur les jeunes
esprits en devenir nos corps c'est la
corruption de leurs esprits
les films de national geographic et de
la série l'âge de glace ont été produits
par une société de francs maçons rupert
murdoch et la twenty century fox la
société de production franc maçonne
universal a créé jurassic park et le
petit noah ou la vallée des merveilles
il appartient à comcast dont les
principaux actionnaires sont les franc
maçons jpb
et rothschild la discovery channel
chaîne de télé pour les jeunes qui
proposent de nombreux documentaires sur
les dinosaures à pour conseiller
financier rothschild et fil limited
bon ben voilà la honte on baigne dans le
complot le plus total mais encore là là
c'est l'industrie du cinéma et de la
divine du divertissement même même en
imaginant qu'ils sont francs-maçons
encore une fois moi je me sens pas
concerné en tant que chercheur l'ancien
étudiant en paléontologie michael force
elle a clamé pendant une interview
radiophonique avec le paléontologue
réputé jack corner que ce dernier était
un fraudeur complet qui fabrique des
preuves et perpétue le mythe des
dinosaures tard en tentant en abattant
si c'est michael fort celle qu'il l'a
dit oui
il ajouta j'ai débuté ma carrière dans
le domaine de la paléontologie j'ai
arrêté mes études après avoir réalisé
que tout l'ensemble n'était qu'une vaste
fumisterie
c'est n'importe quoi presque tous les
prétendus ce que les deux musées sont en
fait des moulages en plâtre on dit même
franchement aujourd'hui dans les
documentaires que c'est pour préserver
les eaux ouais c'est ça j'ai eu du mal
quand j'étais étudiant surtout parce que
je ne pouvais pas faire la différence
entre un oeuf fossilisés une pierre
ordinaire c'est pour ça que tu as arrêté
d'être paléontologues du conte bon alors
attends un oeuf fossilisés donc un oeuf
fossilisé voilà ça c'est la structure
d'un oeuf fossilisé à l'intérieur vous
voyez le remplissage de sédimentaires et
à la surface vous voyez les coquilles
voilà ça c'est un oeuf fossilisé c'est
comme ça qu'on fait la différence
monsieur sur un sur un galet à la con il
y aurait pas de coquille
je suis désolé de revenir à des bases un
évidement mais mais voilà donc c'est
peut-être pour ça que tu n'as pas été
plus loin en paléontologie c'est parce
que tu étais nul et bien sûr il n'y a
pas de différence non s'il ya une
différence viennent de la montrer j'ai
été traité comme un pestiféré bas comme
un débile un surtout un j'imagine quand
j'ai refusé de marcher dans leur
propagande et j'ai aussitôt arrêté les
cours à mes dons qu'il a well as il a
vraiment tout juste commencé les cours
en fatigue c'était juste un nul ça va ça
me rappelle moi j'ai eu un étudiant
créationnistes uns et pas un petit
créationnistes
un créationniste terre jeunes mais voilà
on lui a montré les choses on lui a
montré il a demandé à voir les choses on
les lui a montré on lui a montré tous
les petits points qu'on avait on a
montré comment on connecte et les points
et il a accepté notre argumentaire dont
je veux dire il ya une différence entre
être con et être créationnistes il ya
des créationnistes qui sont prêts à
accepter l'argument terre et il a tout à
fait accepté que les fossiles étaient
réels que notre discours tenait la route
et au final on l'a enfin je veux dire il
était convaincu il était convaincu qu'on
était de bonne foi et alors après il
était toujours pas d'accord avec nous ça
c'est certain
du moins il a pas il a refusé de
l'admettre mais ce qui est certain c'est
que c'était certainement hélas là où
c'est formidable c'est que ça a été
certainement notre plus brillantes
étudiants en tout cas de la promo dont
il faisait partie donc donc ces êtres
créationnistes ça veut pas dire être con
mais ça
encore faut-il être ouvert d'esprit ce
qui devait pas être le cas de celui là
les dinosaures n'ont jamais existé tout
ce bazar n'est que du grand guignol
ils ne font que prendre une paire de
vieux os en l'effacement pur enfer laden
dernières pièces à conviction à la
manière du monstre de frankenstein
si les dinosaures existe et on les
aurait mentionné dans la bible bas voilà
un étudiant un étudiant par les autos
logis mais surtout un croyant fanatique
voilà nous avons tous été dupé et c'est
inadmissible mais ensemble nous pouvons
le pouvons le stopper stoppez dire la
nuit là il a visiblement même pas fait
l'effort il est juste allé en cour en
fait il n'a jamais franchi la porte du
labo il est juste allé en cour il a dit
à il a vu les images au tableau il a dit
à ses faux vous nous montrez pas des
réseaux bah oui on va pour vous montrer
des réseaux sur un powerpoint 1 c'est un
peu difficile qui même en tp on vous
montre des moulages parce que 200
étudiants qui doivent tripoter les
fossiles au bout d'un moment les
fossiles vont péter on préfère vous
montrer les moulages au moi s'il vous
lâche pas et on en fait un autre est
évidemment celui là est pas allé plus
loin que la salle de cours alors
fatalement bas ont une fois de plus un
sortez vous les doigts du cul est allé
visiter les musées est allé voir les
paléontologues
beaucoup disent qu'avec la radio mettrie
la très contestée méthodes de datation
au radiocarbone nantes j'ai même pas
envie de lire ce à quoi j'ai même pas
envie dire ce à quoi le mec qui va nous
parler de carbone 14 alors qu'on parle
de dinosaures allez vous faire [ __ ] le
carbone 14 ne marche pas sur les
dinosaures ont fait remonter les
fossiles de dinosaures des dizaines de
millions d'années non pas avec du
carbone 14 ans le carbone 14 s'est
limité à cinquante mille ans les
fossiles qui ont des millions d'années
on se sert pas durable du carbone 14
leur authenticité et donc prouver le
fait est pourtant que les méthodes
utilisées pour dater les fossiles
consiste non pas à mesurer les fossiles
de même mais les roches entre près
desquels ils ont été découverts non ça
c'est vrai le carbone 14 peut
s'appliquer directement sur les os mais
pas les autres méthodes
donc visiblement ils te parle du
radiocarbone mais il n'a pas vraiment
idée de quoi il parle
mais voilà c'est vrai on date canton
date des fossiles de dinosaures en date
la roche dans laquelle le fossile se
trouve
sachant que le fossile lui même ne peut
pas être plus vieux que la roche dans ne
peut pas être plus jeune que la roche
dans laquelle il se trouve
sinon il se trouverait pas dedans ça
s'appelle la gravité on ne peut pas
poser un verre sur une table s'il n'y a
pas une table avant et on ne peut pas
recouvrir un ver de terre si le jeu de
mot pardon jeunes monos voulu on peut
pas rouvrir un verre de sable si le
verre n'est pas sous le sable d'abord
donc
donc oui on date en date ce qu'il ya
autour généralement même ce qui arrive
c'est qu'on date on essaye de dattes et
si possible une heure une roche
volcanique qui est au dessus est une
roche volcanique qui est en dessous
comme ça on a un intervalle voilà on
trouve surtout les fossiles près de la
surface de la terre
et si un animal contemporain de mémoire
dans le secteur les paléontologues lui
attribueraient probablement la même
ancienneté
on trouve surtout les fossiles près de
la surface de la terre bat sauf si tu
creuses
bah oui si tu cherches à la surface tu
trouveras pas des faux cils ailleurs
qu'à la surface
et si un animal contemporain devait
mourir dans le secteur les
paléontologues verrait la différence
entre le fossile qui pèse 15 tonnes et
le et l'animal moderne dont les eaux
sont tous blancs tout propre est
vachement légers alors que le je veux
dire un truc qui a passé 60 millions
d'années dans la roche ça une sale
gueule
j'annonce tout de suite je les montre et
tout à l'heure donc non n'est pas de
vente aux logs ferait très bien la
différence août bal le docteur margaret
elder écrit dans un de ses livres les
scientifiques ont été très impressionnés
par le potentiel de la radio mais tri
pour réussir à dater de manière fiable
l'âge de certaines variétés de roche
ils ne pensent plus ainsi ayant eu en
ayant tenu à s'occuper de plusieurs
dates calculé qu'ils sont trop jeunes ou
trop vieille comparée à celle qu'ils
attendaient les scientifiques admettent
aujourd'hui que le processus comporte
beaucoup plus d'incertitudes qui ne le
supposait auparavant oui heureusement
heureusement que c'est pas la seule
méthode qu'on utilise pour dater les
roches ya pas que leur radiométrie il ya
aussi les inversions de champs
magnétiques et il ya la datation
évidemment relative c'est à dire la
datation des fossiles les uns par
rapport aux autres sans compter les
nombreuses et les innombrables autres
de natation la datation au zircon la
natation bref donc heureusement on
n'utilise plus d'une méthode un ouh là
là on a failli se faire piéger sur ce
coup là j'ai eu chaud hein
le public ne sait presque rien sur les
incertitudes de la datation des roches
oui oui oui je d'accord le public ne
sait presque rien sur l'imprécision de
l'adaptation des roches à part quand on
dit que c'est la plus ou moins un
million d'années près quoi ce qui est
une imprécision monumental déjà bref
l'apprécient la pression reçu par la
plupart des gens et que de nombreuses
roches sur le ter sont extrêmement
variés que la technologie existe pour
faire des mesures précises de leur âge
les scientifiques lui ont pris de plus
en plus une conscience que les mesures
faites par les machines peuvent n'a rien
à nous dire sur l'âge réel d'une roche
ne faut pas déconner l'âge réel d'une
roche
non c'est vrai dans l'absolu l'âge réel
de la roche on l'aura jamais on n'en par
contre on peut réduire à un intervalle
quand même conséquent
conséquemment restreint voilà j'ai envie
de dire on peut restreindre l'intervalle
de façon significative par contre ça
c'est clair
le chaînon manquant plus tard par les
deux dinosaures est le chaînon manquant
ça va commencer à me casser les couilles
d'une impression hulala déjà de jeu je
suis franchement agacé l'une des
principales raisons du besoin d les
volent des évolutionnistes de
l'existence des dinosaures était de
répondre aux problèmes complexes et
histoire dans la théorie de l'évolution
c'est pas vrai je les ai déjà dit à
savoir les animaux aquatiques qui se
transforment en animaux terrestres les
reptiles qui deviennent des animaux et
les plumes qui volent et deviennent des
oiseaux ainsi que d'autres va-t-il
évoluant en animaux à sang chaud il vit
pas pour une mamelle et demain des
mammifères grâce à sa chronologie
imaginaire de plusieurs millions
d'années donc maintenant on argumente
même plus on balance tout de suite la
purée est la diversité d'apparence
supposé transitoire des dinosaures c'est
pas vrai je veux dire les dinosaures ils
répondent qu'à une seule de ces trois
questions donc l'establishement
paléontologique s'est débrouillé pour
que différents dinosaure marin reptiles
et oiseaux bavards pour ça sachant
qu'ils parlent de dinosaures non aviens
les dinosaures marasme et reptiles
mammifères comblé
combler ce fossé de nombreux
professionnels et experts en ce domaine
on compte en contester ces découvertes
au fur et à mesure de leur arrivée
le docteur storrs paulson allez allons
vérifier monsieur storrs olson est
qualifié ou pas c'est un ornithologue
voilà c'est pas un paléontologue
le docteur storrs olson scientifique
démissionner n'écrivez l'idée des
dinosaures à plumes et d'oiseaux
descendants des terres des théropodes
par exemple le velociraptor qu'on va
dans jurassic park effectivement
diffuser par un nombre de scientifiques
et les agissements dans le concert avec
certains éditeurs de nature une célèbre
revue national geographic de mieux même
darlan défenseurs de cette croyance et
cherchant avec partialité à y convertir
les autres vérités et passage de preuves
dans un crime aux scientifiques soigne
ou pas ont figuré parmi les premières
victimes de leur programme qui est un
débat qui en est qui est en passe de
devenir l'un des plus grands canulars
scientifiques de l'époque
lalala lalala microraptor le fossile
voici le fossile de microraptor c'est
pas une reconstitution c'est pas une
invention il ya voilà c'est un squelette
de dinosaure longue que les dans le coup
en forme de s
bref tout ce qui caractérise les
dinosaures mais avec des plumes
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut de plus voilà
c'est c'est la photo du faux si l'on
peut pas faire mieux que ça bref donc
oui les dinosaures avaient des plumes et
on le voit sur les fossiles pas
seulement sur les reconstitutions on n'a
jamais trouvé de plumes sur des fossiles
de dinosaures je viens de vous montrer
le contraire malgré bien entendu
quelques tentatives de canular le dr
holton disait de rajouter des plumes
étaient du bot disait que rajouter des
plumes et et du battage médiatique du
fantasme de la propagande une
affabulation sans queue ni tête et un
canular allez on va aussi aller chercher
voilà vélo si raptor uma allons voir
l'une n'a de velociraptor que voici que
voilà
alors donc ça c'est l'os de velociraptor
et sur l'os de bercy encore pareil on
voit les petites roues d'insertion des
plumes
donc voilà
que dire de plus à part que on a toutes
les bonnes raisons de croire que les
dinosaures enfin que certains dinosaures
avaient des plumes dans les années 90 on
aurait trouvé de nombreux fossiles la
plume de schiele bizarrement proche de
l'usiné gong
oui mais le zigbee favori des squelettes
il fabrique pas des squelettes en
plaques comme le microraptor qu'on
trouve justement dans cette région la
face et des squelettes d'ailleurs point
car en plus c'est des squelettes qui
sont sur des plaques
donc c'est pas des squelettes qu'on peut
préparer mais après examen le docteur
timothy roe donc là il va certainement
parler du microraptor a constaté que le
prétendu confuciusornis était un canular
élaboré et ben voilà il se plante et
c'est pas un confuciusornis était harkis
aux raptor il a dit il a aussi découvert
que le spécimen archéo raptor bon là au
moins il yn'a qu'on aurait découvert
dans les années 90 était composé de
hausse provenant de cinq animaux
différents
ouais mais bon c'est quand même des
autres dinosaures qui portait des plumes
même si ça provenait de cinq dinosaures
différent quand le docteur représente à
ces découvertes à national geographic le
dinosaure lui a répondu eh bien ils ont
tous été trafiqués bas les arcs et aux
raptor oui enfin l'archéo raptor les
cinq animaux les cinq possibles qui ont
servi refaire lors qu'il aura tort
national geographic poursuivi ensuite sa
conférence de presse de médias raconte
est faux site d'arqués orateurs étaient
authentiques et qu'ils constituaient le
chaînon manquant dans la théorie de
l'évolution
baa national geographic a essayé de
sauver les meubles en rappelant qu
effectivement les cinq animaux en
question étaient des dinos été aussi des
fossiles de dinosaures qui portait des
plumes bout cette saison essayer de
sauver la le recul quoirin le lien on
peut pas leur reprocher cet article 2
novembre 99 du national geographic a été
retiré après qu'on ait démontré que le
fossile d'intérieur d'arqués orateurs
étaient une fraude douala la chronologie
elle pue du cul en 1999 le magazine
national geographic a été pris la main
dans le sac en présentant dans un
article fantaisiste haut en couleurs le
chaînon manquant leur arc et aux raptor
a été supposé étayer le principe de base
de la théorie de l'évolution à savoir
que les dinosaures avait lentement
évolué avec des sur des millions
d'années leur prof consistait en un
fossile sur lequel des marques ont
soigneusement réparties donnait
l'impression d'une créature mi
dinosaures me why they l'escroquerie fut
découvert pendant un scanner qui révéla
l'artifice oui par timothy roe qui est
un paléontologue aussi le magazine dû
admettre contrat et forcé que le dit
que le fossile et est une création
humaine encore robin coup fed
oui mais ouais c'est timothy roe est un
paléontologue et heureusement qu'on a
pas que larqué aura tort on a aussi tout
un manadier millions maintenant à des
fossiles comme ça qu'ils montrent pas à
pas l'évolution des dinosaures et
oiseaux et pas seulement en chine
on en a aussi en allemagne par exemple
puis on a le velociraptor de mongolie et
puis on a bref les battles les
paléontologues prétendre que
l'archaeopteryx est une forme
transitoire d'oiseaux ayant évolué à
partir des dinosaures l'archaeopteryx
lui il a été scanné des milliards de
fois je peux te l'annoncé avec les
techniques les plus pointues c'est pas
du faux l'archaeopteryx alors des là tu
t'engages sur une penses tu t'engages
sur une pente glissante là mais cette
théorie tombe à l'eau façade écrasante
preuve du contraire rouge de mandat
libre notre espèce comme le
confuciusornis le liaoning ornis et
l'élu l'eau avis se sont avérées
contemporain de l'archaeopteryx est
impossible à différencier des oiseaux
actuels mais dis donc je croyais qu'on
pouvait pas s'y fier à ces in animals là
alors on peut s'y fier quand ça
t'arrange et pas quand ça t'arrange et
on peut ne pas s'y fier quand ça
t'arrange pas c'est ça c'est c'est une
girouette en fait c'est pas un
confuciusornis non mais sérieusement
bref bas
le paradoxe le paradoxe phylogénétique
monsieur ne comprend pas que qu'un
animal peut avoir une morphologie
archaïque et continuer à vivre tel le
coelacanthe eh oui donc oui
l'archaeopteryx était une espèce très
avancé enfin l'archaeopteryx a vécu en
même temps que des oiseaux beaucoup plus
qui ressemblait beaucoup plus à des
oiseaux modernes comme le con sus ornis
ça veut juste dire que l'archaeopteryx
provient d'une branche évolutif qui est
plus ancienne que confuciusornis et qui
a perduré comme le coelacanthe donc
c'est pas impossible
alan fait du tchad de l'université de
caroline du nord l'un des plus célèbres
aux ornithologues monde et donc pas
paléontologues a déclaré j'ai étudié les
crânes d'oiseaux pendant 25 ans mais pas
celui d'archaeopteryx et genevois
pourtant aucun point en commun aucun nid
d oiseau descendants de théropodes sera
à mon avis ce qui mettra le
paléontologue du xxème siècle dans le
plus grand embarras
bah oui les crânes oiseaux adultes
peut-être mais quand tu étudies les
crânes d'oiseaux quand ils sont à l'état
d'embryon
ils ont une fenêtre en théorie terre
comme les dinosaures ils ont quand tu
étudies le corps des oiseaux ils ont une
longue queue à l'état d'embryon comme
les dinosaures et la posture bipèdes des
oiseaux et partager avec les dinosaures
fait qu'il n'ya pas au cul ya pas aucun
point commun entre les dinosaures et les
oiseaux
larry matin larry martin pas les
ornithologues à l'université du kansas
j'en ai marre de vérifier dit j'avoue
que si je devais encourager l'origine
dinosaur yens des oiseaux avec ses
caractères je serai très gênée d'avoir
un rempart les bains je sais pas
archéoptéryx c'est juste un corps de
dinosaures avec des plumes d'oiseaux
dessus alors qu'est ce qui te faut de
plus comme preuve que les oiseaux et
dinosaures que les oiseaux descendent
des dinosaures au bout d'un moment même
c'est l'idée même si les dinosaures
avaient évolué en oiseau pour combler
les lacunes dans la théorie de
l'évolution cela n'explique pas les
oiseaux n'ont pas les dinosaures n'ont
pas évolué en oiseau pour combler les
lacunes de la théorie de l'évolution qui
je ne sais pas quel paragraphe suivant
mais je pense que je vais m'arrêter là
la jambe j'ai mal cela n'explique pas
comment une chose comme la mouche
domestique commune aurait pu évoluer les
mouches agitent leur zèle à un rythme
cinq fois par seconde la plus légère
discordance vibratoire leur ferait
perdre l'équilibré les ferait tomber
mais cela ne se produit jamais comment
pourrait-elle faire évoluer une capacité
aussi étonnante est aussi spécialisée
pourquoi n'at-on jamais découvert de
dinosaures avant la renaissance
évolutionniste du milieu du dix ça fait
beaucoup de questions débiles ça alors
la façon dont des mouches agitent leur
zèle est extrêmement différente de celle
dont les oiseaux agitent leur zèle en
l'occurrence les
on agite leur zèle les ailes des mouches
sont connectés à la cuticule donc à la
l'exosquelette de la mouche et les
exosquelettes vibre comme une corde de
guitare sune effet des muscles qui y
sont accrochées donc en fait les muscles
les fonds à agiter 500 fois par seconde
simplement comme vous fait agiter une
corde de guitare en la frottant donc
vous n'êtes pas obligé de bouger le
doigt 500 fois par seconde c'est pareil
pour les ailes de la mouche et ça et
c'est un mécanisme d'une simplicité
remarquable c'est juste le même principe
qu'une corde de guitare donc et ça fait
bouger les ailes 500 fois par seconde ce
qui éventuellement fait décoller la
mouche parce qu'inévitablement j'ai même
envie de dire fait décoller la mouche
donc parce que c'est très léger une
mouche donc voila vous fait bouger dl500
fois par seconde forcément à l'école
août
donc ta complexité irréductible de merde
parce que je t'ai vu venir la complexité
irréductible de merde tu te la mets au
fion pourra t'on jamais des coûts
pourquoi at-on jamais découvert de
dinosaures avant le dix neuvième siècle
encore une fois ce n'est pas le cas
pourquoi les paléontologues pense-t-il
pouvoir reconstituer l'espèce entière
d'un animal est apte à partir de
quelques dents et bien parce que les
dents des animaux applique qu'ils ont un
crâne et que le crâne implique qu'ils
ont un squelette et que ses dents sont
différentes d'une espèce à une autre
donc on est capable d'identifier ses
dents les de savoir à quelle espèce il
appartenait pourquoi tant de découvertes
de dinosaures se sont-elles avérée des
canulars pour l'instant tu en as parlé
que d'une archéo raptor pourquoi
pourquoi tous les pourquoi tous les
fossiles de dinosaures authentiques sont
ils gardaient souplesse en possibilité
d'une analyse indépendante déjà répondu
à cette question
pour comment se fait-il que l'érosion et
l'exposition aux éléments n'est pas
détruit toutes ses empreintes et
fossiles censé être vieux 2000
d'année ben déjà ça répond partiellement
à ta question du comment ça se fait
qu'on n'en trouve pas plus déjà que tu
poses est tout à l'heure pour quoi on
trouve pas plus de tyrannosaure on devra
en trouver des millions c'est parce que
l'exposition aux éléments et l'érosion
les détruit et aussi comment se fait-il
que l'exposition et l'érosion des n'a
pas détruit tous ces fossiles mais en
réalité c'est précisément l'érosion qui
permet de trouver ces fossiles
on va pas creuser tout la croûte
terrestre continue et les fossiles on
attend que l'érosion les expose nigauds
si les dinosaures avaient été balayés
par la chute d'une météorite ou par une
autre catastrophe mondiale de ce genre
pourquoi les autres espèces d'animaux
qui fusent est aujourd'hui n'ont ils pas
subi aussi cette disparition
si une catastrophe a eu lieu dans le
passé
pourquoi les survivants ont survécu ce
serait ça là c'est ça la question c'est
pourquoi les survivants survécu bas
parce que tous ceux qui se sont éteints
sont marc dudule espèce de bidules
cellule surtout venant de quelqu'un qui
doit croire au mythe de l'arche de noé
commun c'est nul comme allumant quoi si
les dinosaures avaient été balayés par
la chute d'une météorite ou par une
autre catastrophe mondiale de ce sport
pourquoi les autres espèces d'animaux
qui existent aujourd'hui n'ont ils pas
subi aussi cette disparition a baissé
parce qu'ils existent aujourd'hui quoi
c'est bien pour ça qu'ils existent
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'ils ont pas
suivi cette disparition
la réponse est dans la question quoi il
ya bien d'autres questions qui demandent
réponse avant que des gens sains
d'esprit puisse envisager l'existence
des dinosaures autrement que comme un
mythe évolutionnisme évolutionniste dia
commode non je te suis je te suis
complètement faut être complètement
dagne pour faire ce que je suis en train
de faire en ce moment
fo est un grand malade pour s'infliger
de telle ou leur un vrai bon gros malade
l'establishment des paléontologues un
pouvoir de contrôle sur les choix des
hypothèses incluses dans les manuels et
les cours ce cela oui c'est cela je ne
résiste pas un c'est ça oui on a un
pouvoir de décision sur les hypothèses
incluses dans les manuels ou les cours
alors vous allez ouvrir un livre de svt
de terminale s spécialité svt et compter
le nombre de pages dans lesquelles on
parle de dinosaures ou même ne serait-ce
que d'évolution en général s'il y en a
plus que quatre déjà vous gagnez un
point de respect en plus ce qui vous
amènera pas bien haut ça je dois bien
l'admettre mais honnêtement s'il n'y a
plus que quatre pages
je suis content honnêtement donc ouais
un pouvoir de contrôle sur du quasiment
rien donc au final ça revient à rien
quoi les élèves et étudiants vont ainsi
être conditionnée à une pseudo réalité
contrôlée par le contenu des textes et
l'autorité de l'enseignant temps en
temps oui c'est l'enseignant et son
autorité dans les classes qui je jouis
l'autorité de l'enseignant mais bien sûr
un bref exemple concret on trouve par
hasard une dent sur un site de fouilles
à partir de cette dent on devine le
reste du squelette bah si c'est une dent
de vache
oui on va deviner que ces matches donc
on va deviner le reste du squelette tête
de noeud et ça marche aussi avec les
dinosaures
ce n'est pas une plaisante et une
plaisanterie l'intégralité du programme
paléontologique dans le domaine des
dinosaures est une imposture
heureusement que l'intégralité du
programme paléontologique est tout petit
et qui ne pourra se dire voire même
inexistant je m'aime pas sûr qu'ils
aient encore des pages en réalité dans
les livres de svt sur les dinosaures
je me rappelle à mon époque il y avait
il y avait un dinosaure sur la
couverture
je sais pas s'il y est encore mais
c'était un peu pâle son endroit où il y
avait un dinosaure une nouvelle vision
du monde l'évolution a été lancée au 19e
siècle par les gens affluent comme
darwin et marx ils avaient en commun
d'être barbu et ça c'est important le la
franc maçonnerie barbus et c'est un
complot on le néglige beaucoup trop
cependant ces terres de penser qu'on a
fait des premiers qu'on a fait les
points c'est pendant ces terres de
penser pardon qu'on a fait les premières
découvertes de dinosaures ces
découvertes furent telles fabriqué pour
tenter de maquiller les incohérences des
fossiles pour coller avec la théorie de
l'évolution
non non non on les a pas fabriquer et
même la plupart du temps au début en
réalité ça collait pas avec la théorie
de l'évolution l'explosion cambrienne en
particulier c'était plus un problème
contre chose
les problèmes soulevés plus loin à l'une
quelques signaux d'alarmé concernant
l'intégrité de l'industrie du dinosaure
et jette un doute sur l'existence même
des dinosaures c'est la faute à
l'industrie des dinosaures pôle
scientifique des découvertes de
dinosaures qui n'ont été fait que
pendant les deux derniers siècles et
dans des quantités de concentration tout
à fait inhabituel c'est parce qu on les
cherchait pas avant trous du cul
contraire aux lois de la nature et des
probabilités gratte-papier des
découvertes de dinosaures typiquement
pas désintéressée typiquement pas
désintéressée dépourvue d'intérêt
personnel je ne comprends pas la phrase
mais je sais déjà un argument qu'on a
contrecarré avant il ya plein de gens
désintéressés qui trouvent des
dinosaures un genre de préparation à une
exposition publique qui remet en
question la véracité des fossiles et
leurs origines et qui autorise la
possibilité de falsification et de
substitution dos et possibilités
d'activités frauduleuses de manière
systématique non où on rend les choses
visuelles mangeant on rend les choses
tolérable pour le public
quand on les présente au public mais la
communauté scientifique ne se fait pas
de cadeaux existence de dessins
d'artistes d'exposition publique
montrant de périlleuses posture
déséquilibre à compatibles avec les lois
de la physique de base bourse a fait qu
est ce qu on a lié au dessus à
l'argument précédent je veux dire
bon bah les lois de la physique de base
ne sont un problème que pour les gros
dinosaures pas pour les petits très
faible probabilité que tous ces os de
dinosaures est été fossilisé mais
relativement peu d'autres au dos
d'autres animaux mais ça connard c'est
juste parce que tu focalise sur les
dinosaures on trouve des crocodiles
aussi en même temps que les dinosaures
on trouve des tortues en même temps que
les dinosaures entre des insectes on
trouve des plantes qui titille 10 1 est
boutée youtube un gros con parole je
vous ai fait croire pendant tout cet
article qu'on trouvait que des
dinosaures et j'utilise le fait qu'on
trouve que des dinosaures comme argument
non non heureusement qu'ils pas que des
dinosaures en réalité on trouve beaucoup
plus de fragments de carapaces de
tortues que de dinosaures application de
la découverte de dinosaure dans la
théorie de l'évolution et dans la
croyance dole que l'homme a été créé à
l'image de dieu suggérant de possibles
agents dans un jardin secret politiques
des religieux servi à un public naïf et
peu méfiants et en a pas rajouté franc
maçon c'est dommage
manque de financement pour les
organismes et personnes remettant en
question ou affichant à scepticisme pour
chaque découverte et l'exhibition
publipostage vers faut que j'aille
vérifier alors alors sans compter le
fait que je vous ai montré que le
financement de la paléontologie en
france c'était catastrophique maintenant
je vais aller vous montrer le pognon
qu'à la fondation de mme paul tonnes
parce que la fondation templeton c'est
le principe hautement principal
organisme financier c'est principal
organisme financier du créationnisme
explore alors les titres les titres
alors les voilà les montants 234000
dollars 210 mille dollars 207 mille
dollars 220 mille dollars 200 mille
dollars 40 mille dollars 205 mille
dollars 1 million 400 mille dollars 217
1000 dollars un million trois cent
soixante neuf mille dollars je n'en suis
qu'à la page une sur 98
voilà ça vous convient regardez la page
de ça continue c'est encore des fonds
que pour 2010 8,1 et encore des fonds
pour 2018 et si je vais jusqu'à la poche
98 ce qu'on tombe encore
alors ça remonte à 2011 alors je sais
pas jusqu'où ça va la page cateau donné
pages qui correspondent à 2018 mais ça
va jusqu'à la page 3 voilà trois pages
là il ya 6 millions de dollars 1 million
700 mille dollars 2 millions 500 mille
dollars
donc on aille pas donc qu'on aille pas
me faire croire que les mecs ont pas de
pognon
bref bon bah là faut que je termine
parce qu'il ya une alarme qui vient de
se déclencher
mais de toute façon l'article est
presque finie alors manque de
financement pour les organismes et
personnes remettant en question ou
affichant un scepticisme pour les
découvertes et exhibitions public
non non la possibilité existe que des
dinosaures vivants n'est jamais existé
sur terre
ça ne veut rien dire la possibilité
existe que le concept de dinosaures
préhistoriques vivants est était une
fabrication de personnages du 19e siècle
et du xxème siècle poursuivant
probablement un agenda évolutionnisme
évolutionniste anti public et anti
chrétiens
oui c'est possible qu'ils aient des gens
qui étaient anti chrétien au 19e siècle
mais les dinosaures ont pas grand chose
à voir là dedans
au lieu de croire aveuglément à
l'histoire des dinosaures remettre en
question ce qui a été dit est le
meilleur choix ça je vous y invite
il faut pas croire ce qu'on vous dit sur
eux faut pas croire tout ce qu'on veut
d'y aller voir le musée allait voir les
paléontologues demandez-leur le choix
entre croire les mots de l'homme les
évolutionnistes eu les mots de dieu la
bible reste une affaire de choix
oui le choix entre croire le choix de
croire en matière de science entre un
bouquin et les chercheurs et votre choix
on est d'accord
heureusement c'est la fin de tout ça
parce que je commençais vraiment à
fatiguer donc voici la source vous
pouvez partager le lien et rigoler avec
les copains vous pouvez aller lire les
commentaires il y en a en dessous je ne
me fais pas il ya d'autres articles ils
valent leur pesant de cacahuètes
regardez-moi ça un tricératops et
chevauché par un maya
d'ailleurs des preuves que les humains
ont coexisté avec les dinosaures oui
mais qui n'existaient pas les dinosaures
des hommes qui ont vécu au temps des
dinosaures qui n'existe pas voilà voilà
ce qu'on trouve sur ce site messieurs
dames j'aurais dû commencer par là en
fait je me serais je me serais moins
fatigués bon eh bien pour les trois
personnes qui ont tenu jusque là et qui
ont survécu au déclenchement de l'alarmé
merci pour tous ceux ce cri d'alarmé et
mon cri d'alarmé
je m'en remets à vous merci à tous et à
très bientôt sur cette option